Katrina: 那烤肉调料可以上上烤架了是吗
Katrina: So, the BBQ seasoning can go on the grill now, right?
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 出出来往出整吧
Shure: Take it out, bring it out.
Shure: 可以的可以的
Shure: It's fine, it's fine.
Katrina: OK把他们喊出来
Katrina: OK, call them out.
Katrina: 他们说可以出去了
Katrina: They said we can go out now.
Katrina: 那把肉拿出去
Katrina: So, take the meat out.
Alice:放了啊
Alice: Got it.
Tasha: 我们正好有一个盘子
Tasha: We have a plate just right for this.
Alice:go
Alice: Go.
Tasha: 没那个然后可以把那个盘子拿来
Tasha: There's none, so we can use that plate.
Shure: 这温度够
Shure: This temperature is enough.
Alice:差不多了
Alice: Almost there.
Katrina: 嗯 5万块
Katrina: Yeah, 50,000 bucks.
Tasha: 放10个蛋糕就行
Tasha: Just put 10 cakes.
Lucia: 盘子这个盘子good
Lucia: This plate, this plate is good.
Shure: 无敌
Shure: Invincible.
Tasha: 对正好有个盘子刚被我们抽出来了
Tasha: Yeah, we just pulled out a plate.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 真无敌
Shure: Truly invincible.
Katrina: 不会的
Katrina: It won't.
Katrina: 对啊我们6个人
Katrina: Yeah, there are six of us.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yeah!
Jake:大成功
Jake: Great success.
Lucia: 所以所以所以外面是可以了是吗
Lucia: So, so, so it's ready outside, right?
Jake:呃对
Jake: Uh, yeah.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Jake:算是可以了
Jake: I guess it's okay now.
Tasha: 当然可以了
Tasha: Of course, it's okay.
Jake:温度起来了
Jake: The temperature is rising.
Tasha: 温度起来了
Tasha: The temperature is rising.
Jake:火还没完全着完
Jake: The fire isn't completely out yet.
Tasha: 我还没完全到
Tasha: I'm not fully there yet.
Alice:左右怎么是不通风的
Alice: Why is there no ventilation on the sides?
Jake:可以开始考了就是
Jake: We can start grilling now.
Lucia: 我那个杯子在哪里来
Lucia: Where's my cup?
Katrina: 没有任何感触
Katrina: I don't feel anything.
Katrina: 就是觉得好爽
Katrina: It just feels so good.
Tasha: 杯子
Tasha: Cup.
Tasha: 杯子杯子
Tasha: Cup, cup.
Katrina: 在这过养老生活
Katrina: Living a retired life here.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 不是上面80呢
Shure: Isn't it supposed to be 80 up there?
Katrina: 给你看我们住的地方
Katrina: Let me show you where we live.
Jake:我放在哪了找个碗
Jake: Where did I put it? Find a bowl.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Katrina: 我住在2楼
Katrina: I live on the second floor.
Shure: 微微微你50
Shure: Tasha, you have 50.
Tasha: 你可以每个里面放3块3
Tasha: You can put three pieces in each.
Shure: 又给你多30呢
Shure: And you got an extra 30.
Shure: 怎么了不要天天跟我说什么50梗好吗
Shure: What's up? Don't keep mentioning this 50 thing, okay?
Tasha: 嗯铺个底
Tasha: Hmm, lay a base.
Katrina: 到处都有摄像头
Katrina: There are cameras everywhere.
Tasha: 我看铺个底要多少个好吧
Tasha: Let me see how many we need for the base, okay?
Katrina: 看见没有
Katrina: See that?
Shure: 哪天没哪次没给你
Shure: When did I not give it to you?
Katrina: 就是这种
Katrina: Like this.
Tasha: 这么多吧
Tasha: This many, I guess.
Tasha: 大概123 哈哈
Tasha: About 123, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈行我还是数数123456
Lucia: Hahaha, alright, I'll count, 123456.
Katrina: 到处都是电脑
Katrina: There are computers everywhere.
Tasha: 好就铺个底就行这样子
Tasha: Okay, just lay a base like this.
Alice:是着了的
Alice: It's burning.
Shure: 有没有没着的
Shure: Is there any part not burning?
Alice:有有个完全没着的
Alice: Yes, there's a part that's not burning at all.
Katrina: 这我的房间
Katrina: This is my room.
Shure: 哪个
Shure: Which one?
Lucia: 78九个这么多呀
Shure: 最左边那个是吗OK
Tasha: 9-10个吧
Lucia: 行好嘞
Shure: 先把它也拿出去
Shure: 然后一会拿着勺
Shure: 哎你现在这个应该是着了的
Lucia: 它有的会两片粘在一起
Shure: 哎这个着了这个着了来
Lucia: 所以就占的面积小一些
Shure: 你还是先把他这么侧着吧
Tasha: 要不来倒主厨
Jake:哈哈我
Jake:我怎么敢
Shure: 草早这样早他妈好
Jake:哎倒什么呀
Tasha: 就把它倒进去就行
Jake:好好行
Jake:我试试倒多少啊
Katrina: 番茄酱烤肉
Shure: 对放上面
Shure: Yeah, put it on top.
Jake:三分之几
Jake: How much, a third?
Tasha: 倒个七八分满就行
Tasha: Just fill it about 70-80%.
Alice:最左边那个没
Alice: Is the one on the far left done?
Alice:没熟没没
Alice: Not cooked yet, no.
Tasha: 但是要 12个
Tasha: But we need 12 of them.
Jake:三分之
Jake: One third...
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Tasha: 你要倒均匀点吗
Tasha: Do you want to pour it evenly?
Alice:这两边好像都是
Alice: Seems like both sides are...
Alice:这个有一点点
Alice: This one has a little bit.
Lucia: 咦多了
Lucia: Oops, that's too much.
Shure: 这也够呛
Shure: This one's also tricky.
Jake:好那我就慢慢倒
Jake: Alright, I'll pour it slowly then.
Tasha: 不着急要等这个烤出来他才能到
Tasha: No rush, we have to wait until this batch is baked.
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Hmm, got it.
Tasha: 他才能进
Tasha: Then we can move on to the next batch.
Tasha: 进下一锅
Tasha: To the next batch.
Jake:懂了
Jake: Understood.
Jake:那我还是干芒果
Jake: I'll stick to mango then.
Katrina: 哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒
Katrina: Da da da da da da da da da da.
Jake:这芒果不软的
Jake: This mango isn't ripe.
Tasha: 虽然不软
Tasha: Even though it's not ripe
Tasha: 但是我感觉它看起来有啊
Tasha: I feel like it looks okay though.
Katrina: 玻璃杯还是拿一次性杯呢
Katrina: Should we use glass cups or disposable ones?
Tasha: 好像已经有点
Tasha: It seems a bit
Katrina: 拿玻璃杯吧
Katrina: Let's use glass cups.
Lucia: 稍微有点那个氧化了一样
Lucia: It looks a bit oxidized.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 玻璃杯好看一点
Katrina: Glass cups look nicer.
Shure: 玻璃吧
Shure: Glass ones.
Katrina: 就拿这个吧
Katrina: Let's just use this one.
Shure: 有点情调啊
Shure: Adds a bit of ambiance.
Jake:可能就是这种品种吧
Jake: Maybe it's just this variety.
Katrina: 这可以直接喝
Katrina: We can drink this directly.
Katrina: 需要兑东西吗
Katrina: Do we need to mix it with anything?
Jake:有水果刀吗
Jake: Do we have a fruit knife?
Shure: 就是今天买那个吗
Shure: The one we bought today?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 对直接喝就行
Shure: Yeah, just drink it directly.
Shure: 然后你觉得不行你再兑东西
Shure: And if you think it’s not enough, add something else.
Jake:用菜刀也行吧
Jake: Using a kitchen knife is fine too, right?
Tasha: 嗯要求不要太过分
Tasha: Yeah, just don't be too demanding.
Alice:上面有几根
Alice: There are a few on top.
Shure: 上面还有俩
Shure: There are two more on top.
Jake:这不过分吧
Jake: That's not too much, right?
Alice:这个也不行
Alice: This doesn't work either.
Jake:有水果捞切芒果
Jake: There's fruit salad, and you can cut mangoes.
Alice:这个也得点点吧
Alice: This one needs to be a bit more too.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 差不多吧
Tasha: That's about right.
Shure: 行那放放旁边吧
Shure: Alright, then put it aside.
Shure: 他一次只能点着一根
Shure: He can only light one at a time.
Tasha: 进入完全不讲究状态
Tasha: Entering a completely careless state.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 他只有那边那根能点着
Shure: Only that one over there can be lit.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 咖啡豆啊
Katrina: Coffee beans?
Shure: 因为风是往那边吹所以点不着
Shure: Because the wind is blowing that way, it can't be lit.
Tasha: 呃巧克力
Tasha: Uh, chocolate.
Lucia: 巧克力啊没事不用对不起
Lucia: Chocolate, it's okay, no need to apologize.
Katrina: 哦哦对不起
Katrina: Oh oh, sorry.
Katrina: 巧克力
Katrina: Chocolate.
Alice:小火慢炖的
Alice: Slow cook it on low heat.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我
Katrina: Hahaha, I...
Shure: 对好放这吧
Shure: Yeah, put it here.
Katrina: 我的生活常识太匮乏
Katrina: My common sense is so lacking.
Shure: OK然后先放上把这羊排可以弄上
Shure: OK, first put it on, you can put the lamb chops now.
Shure: 哎放这吧放这吧
Shure: Yeah, put it here, put it here.
Alice:但是你待会不好好拿下来呀
Alice: But you won't be able to take it down properly later.
Lucia: 哇这巧克力好香啊
Lucia: Wow, this chocolate smells so good.
Lucia: 可以吃一个吗哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Can I have one? Hahahaha.
Alice:这倒着倍快
Alice: This is so fast when upside down.
Tasha: 可以啊他就是纯巧克力黑巧58
Tasha: Sure, it's pure dark chocolate, 58% cocoa.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 拿拿夹子都是
Shure: Grab it with the tongs.
Katrina: 这能扔了不
Katrina: Can I throw this away?
Katrina: 感觉第一天
Katrina: Feels like the first day.
Shure: 对那个放上放上吧
Shure: Yeah, put that on, put that on.
Lucia: 要先吃一片吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Do you want to eat a piece first? Hahaha.
Alice:可以了
Alice: It's fine.
Tasha: 哈哈我不要
Tasha: Haha, I don't want it.
Shure: 好不行从这往里夹嘛
Shure: Okay, no, clamp it from here.
Lucia: 宇轩要先吃一片吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, do you want to eat a piece first?
Alice:这就是
Alice: This is...
Katrina: 我尝一个
Katrina: I'll try one.
Lucia: 喂你吧要不哈哈哈
Lucia: Here, let me feed you, haha.
Shure: 这其实应该是烤串用的
Shure: This should actually be for barbecue skewers.
Katrina: 好的你喂我吧
Katrina: Okay, you feed me.
Lucia: 健康要先吃一片吗
Lucia: Jiankang, do you want to eat a piece first?
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 我就不喂你了
Lucia: I won't feed you.
Lucia: 自己可以给你倒出来哈哈
Lucia: You can pour it yourself, haha.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 很好熟吧应该
Shure: It should be well cooked, right?
Lucia: 哎呀我再来一片
Lucia: Oh, I'll have another piece.
Jake:这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice:一上来就放这么大块的
Alice: Putting such a large piece on right away.
Jake:这叫什么呀
Jake: What do you call this?
Tasha: 一定要认准这个牌子
Tasha: You have to recognize this brand.
Alice:可以多放点
Alice: You can add more.
Tasha: 百丽
Tasha: Belle.
Tasha: 你菜板忙
Tasha: Your cutting board is busy.
Tasha: 洗了吗怎么感觉这么脏
Tasha: Did you wash it? Why does it feel so dirty?
Jake:加点洋葱味问题不大
Jake: Adding some onion flavor should be fine.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha ah.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这菜板怎么这么脏啊
Tasha: Hahaha, why is this cutting board so dirty?
Katrina: 哇噻哇噻哇噻
Katrina: Wow wow wow.
Jake:这菜板怎么这么脏啊
Jake: Why is this cutting board so dirty?
Tasha: 你这菜刀洗了吗
Tasha: Did you wash this knife?
Jake:菜刀洗了
Jake: The knife is washed.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Alright.
Jake:板是蒜和洋葱
Jake: The board has garlic and onion on it.
Shure: 给你补个光哎
Shure: Let me get you some light.
Katrina: 惠灵顿牛排
Katrina: Wellington steak.
Jake:对哇不要蒜
Jake: Yeah, no garlic.
Lucia: 哇不要蒜
Lucia: Wow, no garlic.
Lucia: 蒜沾到水果上面味道很大的
Lucia: Garlic on fruit would give it a strong taste.
Shure: 看能不能补个暖光
Shure: See if we can get some warm light.
Lucia: 洋葱可能还好一点
Lucia: Onion might be a bit better.
Tasha: 你太过分了
Tasha: You're too much.
Shure: 稍等
Shure: Hold on.
Shure: 好好像没有暖光这选项
Shure: Okay, seems like there's no warm light option.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 把水果也从洗了
Tasha: Also wash the fruit.
Jake:好好水果我也洗一洗
Jake: Sure, I'll wash the fruit too.
Lucia: 没事幸好它还没切开
Lucia: It's okay, luckily it's not cut yet.
Lucia: 要蒜味要沾到水果上真的特别难消掉
Lucia: Garlic flavor on fruit is really hard to get rid of.
Shure: 哪边打会酷一点
Shure: Which side will look cooler?
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Shure: 不知道
Shure: Don't know.
Lucia: 就是你就会吃到那个味道
Lucia: You'll just taste that flavor.
Katrina: 再拿两个杯子
Katrina: Let's get two more cups.
Jake:哈哈好的
Jake: Haha, okay.
Shure: 他也整不着整半天
Shure: He couldn't get it done for a long time.
Tasha: 您来
Tasha: You do it.
Shure: 刚整着一半吧
Shure: Just got halfway done.
Katrina: 这怎么洗嘞
Katrina: How do you wash this?
Tasha: 这个可以
Tasha: This one is okay.
Lucia: 嗯我试试看
Lucia: Hmm, I'll give it a try.
Tasha: 您要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Jake:我可以要
Jake: I can take it.
Katrina: 我好像不会洗青菜
Katrina: I don't seem to know how to wash vegetables.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Like...
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina: 我的认知里好像没有洗青菜这个选
Katrina: I don't think washing vegetables is part of my knowledge.
Tasha: 就他可以
Tasha: He can do it.
Shure: 直接放上面了
Shure: Just put it on top.
Tasha: 阻断他流
Tasha: Block its flow.
Lucia: 生菜确实一般
Lucia: Lettuce is pretty average.
Shure: 卧槽你虎皮
Shure: Whoa, you're peeling it like a tiger.
Lucia: 可能都直接在这放一下好了
Lucia: Maybe we should just leave it here.
Katrina: 择
Katrina: Pick.
Tasha: 好凝视
Tasha: Good stare.
Lucia: 哎小心吃会不会那个会不会烫
Lucia: Hey, be careful when you eat it, it might be hot.
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 咱要不把它
Lucia: Should we...
Lucia: 都掰开吧
Lucia: Just break it apart?
Tasha: 不听
Tasha: Not listening.
Katrina: 嗯应该是掰开了
Katrina: Yeah, it should be broken apart.
Katrina: 然后一片片水洗一下冲一下
Katrina: Then rinse each piece with water.
Shure: 怎么不把他
Shure: Why not...
Shure: 那个最红的那边冲上呢
Shure: Rinse the reddest part?
Lucia: 找个盘子
Lucia: Find a plate.
Katrina: 然后还要干嘛来着
Katrina: Then what else?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Katrina: 哦还要拿两个杯子
Katrina: Oh, we need two cups.
Shure: 你怎么没把他最红的那边冲上
Shure: Why didn’t you rinse the reddest part?
Jake:是不是有点太保守了
Jake: Isn't it a bit too conservative?
Lucia: 把盘拿大点的
Lucia: Get a bigger plate.
Alice:没看见
Alice: Didn't see it.
Lucia: 盘子这盘
Lucia: This plate, this one.
Lucia: 不过这盘子还没用过
Lucia: But this plate hasn’t been used yet.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Jake:我先少弄点啊
Jake: I'll just do a little bit first.
Alice:来段来段快板
Alice: Come on, give us a quick beat.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:好我保守一点保守一点
Jake: Okay, I'll be more conservative.
Lucia: 就它吧
Lucia: Let’s go with this one.
Shure: 同仁堂开的
Shure: It's from Tong Ren Tang
Shure: 本是老药铺
Shure: It's an old pharmacy
Lucia: 啊那这又要再放一下先
Lucia: Ah, then we should let it sit for a bit
Shure: 先生好比甩手自在王
Shure: The master is as free as a king
Tasha: 这个有点多了吧
Tasha: Isn't this a bit much?
Tasha: 不是很保守吗
Tasha: Isn't it supposed to be conservative?
Lucia: 这怎么搞
Lucia: How do we handle this?
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, indeed
Shure: 药王爷就在当中
Shure: The Medicine King is in the center
Shure: 十个名医列两旁
Alice:好来袋炸莓啊
Alice: Alright, let's get some fried berries
Katrina: 我们之间的回忆
Katrina: Our shared memories
Jake:这个多吗
Jake: Is this too much?
Tasha: 这正常吧
Tasha: This is normal, right?
Tasha: 我觉最高就这么高就行了
Tasha: I think the highest it should go is this high
Shure: 草那个该翻个面
Shure: Hey, that needs to be flipped
Jake:保守一点保守一点
Jake: Be more conservative, be more conservative
Jake:太吵了哎
Jake: It's too noisy, hey
Jake:保守一点保守一点
Jake: Be more conservative, be more conservative
Jake:诶诶诶诶诶诶别
Jake: Hey, hey, hey, don't
Shure: 这没个灯真不行
Shure: It's really hard without a light
Jake:别动啊别动啊诶
Jake: Don't move, don't move, hey
Shure: 我看不着肉的色你知道吗
Shure: I can't see the color of the meat, you know?
Alice:嗯让杨老板尝一下
Alice: Hmm, let Jake try it
Jake:我可能会了
Jake: I might get it
Shure: 好家伙先拿
Shure: Alright, take it first
Shure: 老板试毒是吧
Shure: 咱们这员工真牛逼
Shure: Our staff is really impressive
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow
Tasha: 有合关发牌
Tasha: There's a good deal going on
Tasha: 有杨老师在线切蛋糕
Tasha: We have Mr. Yang cutting the cake online
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright
Tasha: 嘿嘿嘿是吧
Tasha: Hehehe, right?
Jake:对哎感觉不错
Jake: Yeah, it feels good
Shure: 这女人这啥都能吃半夜
Shure: Women can eat anything at midnight
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake:挺好玩
Jake: It's fun
Jake:好
Jake: Alright
Tasha: 好玩多玩会
Tasha: It's fun, let's play a bit more
Shure: 不是上面那个
Shure: Not the one on top
Tasha: 哎这个会不会太过分了
Tasha: Hey, isn't this going too far?
Shure: 80那个那个手手续费那个
Shure: The 80, the handling fee, that...
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:我怕最后不够了
Jake: I'm afraid it won't be enough in the end.
Lucia: 你干了什么
Lucia: What did you do?
Lucia: 我刚也在这么想
Lucia: I was just thinking the same.
Lucia: 但是我好像暂时没找到别的地方
Lucia: But it seems like I can't find another place for now.
Lucia: 我打算快点洗
Lucia: I'm planning to wash it quickly.
Alice:感觉这个气都不足了
Alice: Feels like there's not enough gas.
Tasha: 这个厨房就这么小对
Tasha: This kitchen is so small, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Shure: 换一个那就咱把这个吸了
Shure: Then let's switch and absorb this.
Lucia: 咱们人比较多
Lucia: We have quite a few people.
Lucia: 这厨房有点太小了
Lucia: This kitchen is a bit too small.
Shure: 着了吗他俩最后还没着呢
Shure: Are they ready? They haven't started yet.
Lucia: 这么大厨房我觉得两三个人还行
Lucia: In such a big kitchen, I think two or three people are fine.
Lucia: 再多就东西会放不下
Lucia: Any more and there won't be enough space for things.
Tasha: 还有十几分钟这我就烤好了
Tasha: In ten minutes, I'll have this baked.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 那咱外面的进度咋样
Lucia: How's the progress outside?
Shure: 来个猛的
Shure: Go big.
Jake:呃进度
Jake: Uh, progress...
Jake:不知道啊反正5分钟之前进度是0
Jake: I don't know, but five minutes ago, the progress was zero.
Alice:应该有反正这侧面已经着了
Alice: There should be some, this side is already lit.
Alice:一点点
Alice: A little bit.
Lucia: 说明他们进度与指数函数性增长
Lucia: It means their progress is growing exponentially.
Jake:是的是是这么回事
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Jake:是一个呃
Jake: It's a, uh...
Tasha: 维护秀是吧
Tasha: Maintenance show, right?
Shure: 把盖把把盖拔下来
Shure: Remove the cover.
Jake:应该就是就火点着了
Jake: It should just ignite the fire.
Alice:筷子呢
Alice: Where are the chopsticks?
Jake:然后就可以开始了
Jake: Then we can start.
Shure: 筷子在他手
Shure: The chopsticks are in his hand.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Tasha: OK火点着了
Tasha: Okay, the fire is lit.
Lucia: 火点着这是个原爆点
Lucia: The fire is lit, this is a detonation point.
Katrina: 我要我要
Katrina: I want it, I want it.
Tasha: 是个原爆点是的
Tasha: It's a detonation point, yes.
Katrina: 咋了我要证明我自己
Katrina: What's up? I need to prove myself.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 谁会成为我们的普罗米修斯呢
Lucia: Who will be our Prometheus?
Shure: 废物
Shure: Useless.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 要你干什么用
Shure: What are you good for?
Katrina: 生气了
Katrina: I'm angry.
Shure: 等吃吧你就
Shure: Just wait and eat.
Jake:刚刚特意买了一个
Jake: I just bought one specifically.
Jake:就是一瓶酒精然后全撒上去了没有用
Jake: It's a bottle of alcohol, but it didn't work.
Katrina: 就是镊子不好用吗
Katrina: Are the tweezers not good?
Jake:那个碳比较难点
Jake: The charcoal is hard to light.
Jake:碳质量一般
Jake: The quality of the charcoal is average.
Katrina: 应该用那种蜂窝
Katrina: You should use the honeycomb kind.
Katrina: 蜂窝的那个
Katrina: The honeycomb one.
Jake:应该是
Jake: Probably.
Lucia: 它接触氧的面积会比较大一点
Lucia: It has a larger surface area to contact with oxygen.
Katrina: 耶
Katrina: Yay.
Katrina: 只剩一只筷子了
Katrina: There's only one chopstick left.
Jake:听起来是这样
Jake: Sounds about right.
Jake:一只筷子
Jake: One chopstick.
Alice:一开始烤
Alice: Start grilling.
Katrina: 哎我们只有这几双筷子
Katrina: Hey, we only have these few pairs of chopsticks.
Alice:烤肥的会好一点
Alice: It's better to grill the fatty ones.
Alice:因为那个油会滴下去
Alice: Because the oil will drip down.
Shure: 油低下去是吧
Shure: The oil will drip down, right?
Jake:我也好奇那个他什么情况
Jake: I'm also curious about his situation.
Katrina: 我也好奇
Katrina: I'm also curious.
Katrina: 你的那个
Katrina: About yours.
Alice:有希望能熟反正
Alice: Hopefully, it can be cooked anyway.
Lucia: 哎还行吧
Lucia: Hey, it's okay.
Jake:对啊可好了
Jake: Yeah, it's pretty good.
Shure: 咱就吃3分熟今天
Shure: We'll just eat it medium-rare today.
Tasha: 你是刚才就是再分配了一下吗
Tasha: Did you just redistribute it?
Shure: 卧槽这其实很热的
Shure: Damn, it's actually really hot.
Jake:对对对再分配
Jake: Yes, yes, redistributed.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 二次分配
Tasha: Redistribution.
Jake:哈哈哈是的
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:就和谐了嘛
Jake: It's harmonious now.
Shure: 这俩应该是感觉差不多
Shure: These two should feel pretty similar.
Jake:现在很和谐
Jake: It's very harmonious now.
Jake:扶贫现在是
Jake: Poverty alleviation now is...
Jake:看看好现在全面脱贫
Jake: Look, now we've completely eradicated poverty.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 那个大的
Shure: That big one.
Jake:哈哈哈可以吧
Jake: Hahaha, is it okay?
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死
Katrina: Hahaha, so funny.
Lucia: 好家伙
Lucia: Oh my!
Jake:怎么样和谐
Jake: How's the harmony?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Good.
Lucia: 可以非常好
Lucia: Yes, very good.
Tasha: 你看有的很好
Tasha: See, some are really good.
Jake:啊还是有一些先富的人是吧
Jake: Ah, there are still some who got rich first, right?
Katrina: 了
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 哎我觉得里面的这些叶子很干净
Lucia: Hey, I think these leaves inside are really clean.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 不是你看这上面有很多气泡看到了吗
Tasha: No, look, there are many bubbles on top, see them?
Tasha: 啊就这样子
Tasha: Ah, like this.
Jake:哦那我每个都打一会
Jake: Oh, then I should hit each one for a while.
Tasha: 就是因为你可能弄得太低了
Tasha: It's because you might have set it too low.
Tasha: 然后他的气泡就会产生
Tasha: And then the bubbles will form.
Tasha: 这样子会导致他很多空心的就不太
Tasha: This will cause many hollow ones, which isn't too...
Shure: 翻过来应该会好一点
Shure: Flipping it over might be better.
Shure: 是吧火会旺一点
Shure: The fire will be stronger, right?
Jake:就不太明白哎
Jake: I don't really understand, eh.
Tasha: 哎这个
Tasha: Hey, this...
Jake:这个这怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with this?
Jake:这太少了啊
Jake: This is too little, huh.
Shure: 要不然你用这个夹子
Shure: How about using this clamp?
Tasha: 啊没事
Tasha: Ah, it's fine.
Jake:没事还是有低保户
Jake: It's fine, there are still some low-income households.
Katrina: 我带我的筷子来了
Katrina: I brought my chopsticks.
Tasha: 嗯对你把有气泡的就这样子震一震
Tasha: Yeah, shake the ones with bubbles like this.
Lucia: 什么历史遗留问题是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: What a historical problem, right? Hahaha
Shure: 行看着吧
Shure: Alright, let's see.
Jake:哈哈哈对是地质疑的问题
Jake: Hahaha, yes, it's a geological problem.
Shure: 感觉差不多
Shure: Feels almost the same.
Shure: 就翻一翻
Shure: Just flip it over
Tasha: 不然不然它不好吃就不够松软
Tasha: Otherwise, if it's not flipped, it won't be soft and fluffy enough
Shure: 一分钟翻一次就行
Shure: Flipping it once every minute is fine
Jake:哦我每个都摔一摔吧
Jake: Oh, I'll give each one a little shake
Katrina: 只有4个
Katrina: There are only four
Katrina: 他们哦
Katrina: They, oh
Katrina: 还是他没人
Katrina: Or no one
Jake:嗯那这个我怎么加上呢
Jake: Hmm, how do I add this?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Jake:就有一个小的是吧
Jake: There's a small one, right?
Tasha: 算了吧
Tasha: Forget it
Tasha: 中国总有贫困地区的
Tasha: There are always impoverished areas in China 社会问题
Katrina: 有一种早期那种围炉取暖的感觉
Katrina: It has that early feeling of gathering around the stove for warmth
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Lucia: 要遵循事物的发展规律吗
Lucia: Do we have to follow the laws of development?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 很爽的人
Shure: Very cool person
Tasha: 这个还要再洗一下
Tasha: This needs to be washed again
Katrina: 很爽特别这边还特别安静
Katrina: Very cool, especially since it's so quiet here
Lucia: 哈怎么了
Lucia: Ha, what happened?
Lucia: 你以为我个人专业
Lucia: Do you think I'm professional?
Jake:哈哈哈专业太专业了
Jake: Hahaha, too professional
Lucia: 个人简历的专业是白写的哈
Lucia: The professionalism on my resume was written for nothing, ha
Jake:这个你要不写个报告吧
Jake: Why don't you write a report on this?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Shure: 没少咋地
Shure: Not bad
Jake:哈哈怎么了
Jake: Haha, what's up?
Lucia: 一会再拿出来
Lucia: We'll take it out later
Jake:你要干嘛啊
Tasha: 哈哈哈你要不就切芒果吧别再摔了
Tasha: Hahaha, why don't you just cut the mango instead of shaking it?
Jake:哈哈哈对不起对不起
Jake: Hahaha, sorry, sorry
Shure: 也可以
Shure: That's also fine
Katrina: 你可以放桌上呢
Katrina: You can put it on the table
Lucia: 桌上我怕外面灰大一会就
Lucia: I'm afraid the table outside is too dusty
Katrina: 啊那放里面吧
Katrina: Ah, then put it inside
Jake:为啥可以了
Jake: Why, it's fine
Tasha: 好了可以了哈哈哈
Tasha: Alright, it's fine, hahaha
Katrina: 现在感觉还没熟呢
Katrina: It doesn't seem cooked yet
Jake:我挺喜欢摔的
Jake: I really like shaking it
Jake:因为里面有一些气泡
Jake: Because there are some bubbles inside
Shure: 离熟还有点距离
Shure: Still a bit undercooked.
Jake:他还需要我
Jake: He still needs me.
Shure: 放下放下
Shure: Put it down, put it down.
Tasha: 他需要你好
Tasha: He needs you, okay?
Jake:他还需要我
Jake: He still needs me.
Shure: 再烧一会
Shure: Let it cook a bit longer.
Jake:对他还需要
Jake: Yes, he still needs it.
Jake:我我觉得我还可以
Jake: I think I can still...
Jake:有贡献的地方他还需要我
Jake: I can still contribute, he needs me.
Shure: 拿两个盘出来
Shure: Get out two plates.
Shure: 拿三个吧
Shure: Make it three.
Lucia: 那煤能给它敲碎吗
Lucia: Can you break the coal?
Lucia: 我感觉那么大一块确实不太不太好
Lucia: That big piece is really not ideal.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Tasha: 哎我靠
Tasha: Oh my God.
Lucia: 那啥
Lucia: Uh, what...
Jake:不能这么干是吧
Jake: We can't do it like this, right?
Tasha: 呃没必要
Tasha: Uh, no need.
Jake:哦好行
Jake: Oh, okay.
Shure: 可以有那味儿
Shure: Yeah, it has that flavor.
Tasha: 可以了可以了
Tasha: It's good, it's good.
Tasha: 干嘛呢接下来
Tasha: What are we doing next?
Jake:不不有气泡
Jake: No, no, it's bubbling.
Tasha: 去切去
Tasha: Go cut it.
Jake:真有气泡
Jake: It's really bubbling.
Tasha: 真没必要了
Tasha: It's really unnecessary.
Shure: 我真感觉得弄一个
Shure: I really think we need one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈这为什么感觉有
Jake: Why does it feel like...
Jake:有红的颜色
Jake: There's some red color.
Jake:是这个油
Jake: It's the oil.
Tasha: 巧克力可能溶溶了一些可以了
Tasha: The chocolate might have melted a bit, it's fine.
Jake:你看这个是气泡吧
Jake: Look, these are bubbles, right?
Alice:屋内打光灯是别的充电
Alice: The indoor lighting is for charging other things.
Shure: 对补光
Shure: Yeah, for extra light.
Lucia: 这哪里有红的
Lucia: Where's the red?
Lucia: 您绝对色感也太好了吧
Lucia: Your color sense is amazing.
Shure: 咱们都得供电
Jake:哈哈哈哈有这种夸赞吗
Jake: Hahaha, is this a compliment?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你是不是想说这么明显
Lucia: Hahaha, are you trying to say it's so obvious?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 他没有能用充电宝供电的东西
Shure: He doesn't have anything that can be powered by a power bank.
Shure: 这点就很烦
Shure: It's really annoying.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是啊
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah.
Jake:不是不是我说有这种夸赞
Jake: No, no, I mean, there's such praise.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Jake:不是就是
Jake: No, it's just...
Lucia: 真是一种夸赞
Lucia: It's really a compliment.
Lucia: 你学画画很厉害的
Lucia: You're really good at drawing.
Lucia: 会哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:好这么回事
Jake: Alright, that's it.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice:好了起来了
Alice: Okay, it's up.
Jake:可能是我这个眼线的反射
Jake: Maybe it's the reflection of my eyeliner.
Shure: 起来了是吗
Shure: It's up, right?
Jake:我怎么切怎么切
Jake: How do I cut it, how do I cut it?
Tasha: 怎么切直直接切就行
Tasha: Just cut it straight.
Jake:好我就切
Jake: Okay, I'll cut it.
Jake:行我直接切
Jake: Alright, I'll cut it straight.
Lucia: 万一是吧
Lucia: What if, right?
Lucia: 我们退一万步讲
Lucia: Let's take a huge step back.
Jake:对万一今天他就打不着了哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, what if he can't get it today, haha.
Lucia: 今天晚对哈哈
Lucia: Tonight, yeah, haha.
Jake:退一百步就是哈哈哈
Jake: Take a hundred steps back, haha.
Tasha: 我买的我买的
Tasha: I bought it, I bought it.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Tasha: 烤箱温度计
Tasha: Oven thermometer.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 竟然真的是
Tasha: It's actually true.
Lucia: 这个是不是要洗啊这个对对对
Lucia: Shouldn't this be washed? Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 不是要洗啊
Tasha: Doesn't it need to be washed?
Tasha: 是吗对对对
Tasha: Right? Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 牛太牛了
Shure: Amazing, so amazing.
Lucia: 因为皮上沾的太多了
Lucia: Because too much is sticking to the skin.
Alice:炭烧透了
Alice: The charcoal is thoroughly burnt.
Shure: 炭烧透了
Shure: The charcoal is thoroughly burnt.
Jake:我来
Jake: I got it.
Tasha: 给你们洗个碟
Tasha: Let me wash a dish for you guys.
Jake:我来我来研究研究
Jake: Let me take a look at it.
Shure: 人类的一小步
Shure: One small step for man...
Lucia: 不是您这个的正确打开方法
Lucia: That's not the right way to open it.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 哎sorry啊
Lucia: Oops, sorry.
Tasha: 不用sorry吧
Tasha: No need to be sorry.
Tasha: 给您洗个碟
Tasha: Let me wash a dish for you.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 您想怎么切就怎么切
Tasha: Cut it however you like.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Exactly, exactly.
Lucia: 你这个的正确打开方式
Lucia: This is the right way to open it.
Alice:哎你这是碳
Alice: Hey, this is carbon.
Lucia: 现在变成了这样
Lucia: Now it looks like this.
Tasha: 不是这个里面没盒吗
Tasha: Isn't there a box inside?
Lucia: 我给你我给你演示一下啊哈哈
Lucia: Let me show you, haha.
Shure: 没事还没碰到呢
Shure: It's fine, didn't touch it yet.
Jake:有有有还没搞定呢试一下啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah, it's not settled yet, let's try it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:哈哈哈好很正确
Jake: Haha, good, that's correct.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Shure: 碰到了你也就当刚刚没有看到好吧
Shure: If you run into it, just pretend you didn't see it, alright?
Alice:好的那个给老板
Alice: Okay, give that to the boss.
Lucia: 哈哈你知道吗
Lucia: Haha, you know what?
Jake:哈哈哈我也来正确一下
Jake: Hahaha, let me correct it too.
Shure: 是的说犒劳老板
Shure: Yeah, say it's to reward the boss.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Lucia: 打开包成了这样的
Lucia: When I opened the bag, it was like this.
Jake:好好好会了会了我也会了
Jake: Alright, alright, I get it, I get it.
Alice:好老板的死活不是死活
Alice: Okay, the boss's life isn't just his life.
Tasha: 我也会的
Tasha: I can do it too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 老板的命不能让他是命
Shure: The boss's life can't be just his life.
Alice:老板的命
Alice: The boss's life.
Lucia: 这个应该不是你切的问题
Lucia: This probably isn't your cutting issue.
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Awesome.
Tasha: 就有的芒果它就是皮比较容易粘肉
Tasha: Some mangoes have skins that stick to the flesh easily.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:就应该这么打开
Jake: It should be opened this way.
Shure: 也有可能是这个碳太低了
Shure: It could also be that the carbon is too low.
Lucia: 对秉承着我们不浪费的原则
Lucia: Yes, following our principle of not wasting.
Lucia: 就也可以先这样吃一下
Lucia: We can just eat it like this first.
Lucia: 然后那部分的用来用来当馅
Lucia: And then use that part for filling.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Sounds good.
Alice:这边还可以先放点这
Alice: We can also put some of this here.
Alice:这啥也是有温度的
Alice: This also has some warmth.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:可以把串先放到这
Alice: We can put the skewers here first.
Alice:烘着
Alice: To roast them.
Lucia: 外面是不是有什么进展了
Lucia: Is there any progress outside?
Lucia: 我好像听见了碗筷的声音
Lucia: I think I heard the sound of dishes.
Lucia:   哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 给孩子饿成啥了
Tasha: The kid must be starving.
Jake:在敲是吧
Jake: Knocking, right?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 比如说怎么着给它敲
Lucia: For example, how should we knock it?
Lucia: 敲碎一点
Lucia: Knock it into smaller pieces.
Jake:不要切到手呀
Jake: Don't cut your hand.
Jake:那我这个会这个知道
Jake: I know this, I know this.
Jake:这个多少知道一点
Jake: I know a bit about this.
Tasha: 您真的不用争取用一下碘伏了
Tasha: You really don't need to use iodine.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不用争取
Lucia: Hahaha, no need to insist on it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈我尽力
Jake: Hahaha, I'll try my best.
Lucia: 这真不用争取
Lucia: Really, no need to insist.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 您争取不用
Lucia: You try not to use it.
Jake:好争取不用
Jake: Okay, I'll try not to.
Jake:这怎么下来
Jake: How do we take this down?
Tasha: 杨老师你把这盘弄这么脏
Tasha: Jake, you made this plate so dirty.
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh.
Jake:啊哪个盘啊对不起
Jake: Which plate? Sorry.
Lucia: 烤箱盘
Lucia: The oven tray.
Tasha: 拿个纸吧
Tasha: Get a paper.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 这个干净的
Lucia: This one is clean.
Lucia: 我刚只是冲了手的时候擦了一下水
Lucia: I just wiped it when I washed my hands.
Lucia: 哎这为啥有
Lucia: Why is there...
Lucia: 一个撒了的
Lucia: One spilled.
Tasha: 呃不要碰
Tasha: Uh, don't touch it.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 等会我们还要弄进去
Tasha: Wait, we'll put it back in later.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈
Lucia: Mm-hmm, hahaha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这是干净的
Tasha: Hahaha, it's clean.
Shure: 一会差不多算着了
Shure: It'll be about right in a bit.
Lucia: 好的好的好的
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 还还差纸还差纸
Tasha: We still need paper, still need paper.
Lucia: 擦盘子是吧
Lucia: To wipe the plate, right?
Lucia: 反正是那就用昨天肯德基还是啥
Lucia: Anyway, just use yesterday's KFC or whatever.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 这纸这纸
Lucia: This paper, this paper.
Lucia: 为啥是这样
Lucia: Why is it like this?
Lucia: 有点太脏了
Lucia: It's a bit too dirty.
Alice:着了
Alice: It's done.
Lucia: 叮咚
Lucia: Ding dong.
Tasha: 主要这个烤盘烤箱不是借的吗
Tasha: Mainly because this oven tray isn't ours.
Alice:还有吗
Alice: Is there more?
Shure: 还有
Shure: There is.
Tasha: 啊环的时候要是烤的这么
Tasha: Ah, if it's baked like this when we return it...
Alice:在这熄火一会中毒了
Alice: If you turn it off here, it'll get poisoned.
Tasha: 就是都粘在这上面了
Tasha: It'll all stick to it.
Tasha: 就烤完之后就不好清理了对
Tasha: It's just hard to clean after baking, right?
Shure: 还有这个
Shure: There's also this.
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: No more.
Shure: 这应该也是着了吧
Shure: This should be done too, right?
Shure: 还是再再烤烤
Shure: Or bake it a bit more?
Alice:这羊肉不刷油行吗
Alice: Is it okay not to brush oil on this lamb?
Alice:感觉不太行啊
Alice: Feels like it won't work.
Shure: 行吧这本身带油的
Shure: It's fine, it has its own fat.
Shure: 哦那牛排没腌卧槽
Shure: Oh, the steak isn't marinated, damn.
Jake:再来一个
Jake: Do another one.
Alice:我们今天吃原味的
Alice: We're eating it plain today.
Jake:哎哪去了
Jake: Hey, where did it go?
Lucia: 这是几个切出来的呀
Lucia: How many pieces did you cut out?
Jake:这是一个切出来的
Jake: This is one piece.
Lucia: 那还行那还行
Lucia: That's fine, that's fine.
Shure: 就是想尝尝牛肉它到底是什么味
Shure: Just want to taste what beef really tastes like.
Lucia: 我以为是俩呢
Lucia: I thought there were two.
Jake:哈哈哈被吃的太多了
Jake: Hahaha, they got eaten too much.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈没关系继续吃
Jake: Haha, no problem, keep eating.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:准备好了吗
Jake: Are you ready?
Alice:你要不把那羊肉串拿过来点
Alice: Why don't you bring the lamb skewers over?
Jake:准备吃啊
Jake: Ready to eat?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Tasha: OK还挺准的呢
Tasha: OK, it's quite accurate.
Tasha: 这个温度
Tasha: This temperature.
Katrina: 我要何时再回首
Katrina: When will I look back again?
Lucia: 薇薇可以吃芒果了
Lucia: Tasha, you can eat the mango now.
Tasha: 不是你一个芒果就算切出这么多
Tasha: No way, you managed to cut that much from one mango?
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 我以为是两个切的呢
Tasha: I thought you used two.
Shure: 让我在那边再推他吗
Shure: Should I push him over there again?
Tasha: 我还想挺不错的呢
Tasha: I think it's pretty good.
Lucia: 哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Jake:好那那我再切一个
Jake: Alright, then I'll cut another one.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 把机器往那边弄点
Shure: Move the machine a bit over there.
Lucia: 毕竟刚才那个皮上沾了很多
Lucia: After all, that peel had a lot on it.
Jake:这个皮上应该也沾不少
Jake: This peel probably has a lot too.
Alice:希腊掌管烧烤的神
Alice: The Greek god of BBQ.
Lucia: 如果有水果刀可以那样削着皮切
Lucia: If we had a fruit knife, we could peel and cut it like that.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Shure: OK最后一块
Shure: OK, the last piece.
Tasha: 但是咱家没有
Tasha: But we don't have one.
Tasha: 我们不是有个削皮刀吗
Tasha: Don't we have a peeler?
Lucia: 小心手
Lucia: Be careful with your hand.
Tasha: 好像不行
Tasha: It doesn't seem to work.
Lucia: 削对
Lucia: Peel it right.
Lucia: 削一套好
Lucia: Peel a set nicely.
Lucia: 削不了这个
Lucia: Can't peel this.
Lucia: 只能削红薯土豆
Lucia: Only good for sweet potatoes and potatoes.
Jake:来试试用一些手法
Jake: Come on, let's try using some technique.
Shure: 往那边推吗
Shure: Push it over there?
Tasha: 什么手法秘制
Tasha: What technique, secret recipe?
Katrina: 牛逼
Katrina: Awesome
Shure: 牛逼把他们全叫来了
Shure: Awesome, you got everyone here
Jake:这个就是
Jake: This is it
Jake:慢一点
Jake: Slow down a bit
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Shure: 真够烤的这羊排
Shure: These lamb chops are really roasted well
Tasha: 辣椒面是
Tasha: The chili powder is...
Shure: 薄的这个我感觉可以拿出来
Shure: The thin one, I think it can be taken out
Tasha: 不知道拿去
Tasha: I don't know, take it out
Shure: 就这一个是没问题的
Shure: This one is fine
Lucia: 呃外面吗
Lucia: Uh, outside?
Lucia: 也行我先给他们拿过去吧
Lucia: Alright, I'll take it to them first
Tasha: 哎这还有个孜然
Tasha: Hey, there's also some cumin
Tasha: 这什么东西啊芝麻
Tasha: What's this, sesame?
Lucia: 芝麻哎呀
Lucia: Sesame, oh no
Shure: 小心那个别碰着那铁子
Shure: Be careful, don't touch that iron
Lucia: 拿过去吧
Lucia: Take it over
Lucia: 看能不能用着
Lucia: See if you can use it
Tasha: 这个地方等会要放蛋糕
Tasha: This place is where we'll put the cake later
Shure: 真能吃咱先偷偷造一个来来来
Shure: You can really eat, let's secretly make one first, come on, come on
Tasha: 你旁边那个架子
Tasha: The shelf next to you
Alice:没熟
Alice: It's not cooked
Shure: 没事这稍微有点
Shure: It's okay, just a bit
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Lucia: 有什么新的进展吗
Lucia: Any new progress?
Lucia: 这个辣椒面和那个芝麻
Lucia: This chili powder and sesame
Lucia: 如果需要撒的话
Lucia: If you need to sprinkle it
Shure: 行先放那吧
Shure: Alright, just put it there first
Katrina: 正在等待中哈哈
Katrina: Waiting, haha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Shure: 就是没灯
Shure: It's just no lights
Shure: 说实话你问问杨老板
Shure: To be honest, ask Jake
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Shure: 能不能想办法给这补个光
Shure: Can we find a way to add some light here
Lucia: 啊他不是有那个影影
Lucia: Doesn't he have that shadow thing?
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Tasha: 给你讲个恐怖故事
Tasha: Let me tell you a scary story
Lucia: 影楼影城
Lucia: Shadow studio
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 不是影楼影棚灯吗
Lucia: Isn't it the studio lights?
Tasha: 我哥他以前就是切西瓜
Tasha: My brother used to cut watermelons.
Jake:然后呢手没了
Jake: And then he lost his hand.
Tasha: 手就切下来了
Tasha: His hand got cut off.
Jake:就切下来了
Jake: Got cut off.
Lucia: 这地方这地方的店算了
Lucia: This place, the shops here, forget it.
Jake:就整个手嘛
Jake: The whole hand.
Tasha: 烧烤组
Tasha: Barbecue group.
Shure: 火越来越旺了
Shure: The fire is getting bigger.
Lucia: 因为外面有点暗
Lucia: Because it's getting a bit dark outside.
Shure: 越来越唧唧冒油了
Shure: It's sizzling and oil is splattering more.
Lucia: 他们现在就是在打着手电筒看
Lucia: They're using flashlights to see now.
Lucia: 那个就是烤箱里面的
Lucia: That's inside the oven.
Katrina: 嗯嗯再来一个牛排
Katrina: Hmm, let's have another steak.
Shure: 那牛排
Shure: That steak...
Lucia: 不是烤箱烤炉里面的情况
Lucia: It's not about the oven conditions.
Alice:这是羊排
Alice: This is lamb chops.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Oh.
Jake:我想想
Jake: Let me think.
Lucia: 但是我感觉
Lucia: But I feel like...
Lucia: 咱们这个插对一个插板也不够长
Lucia: Our plug here isn't long enough even if it's plugged in.
Shure: 不行煎了吧
Shure: No, let's fry it.
Jake:电线弄不出去
Jake: The wire can't reach outside.
Shure: 我去我去
Shure: I'll do it, I'll do it.
Shure: 我去厨房先给大家煎俩牛排吃
Shure: I'll go to the kitchen and fry a couple of steaks for everyone.
Lucia: 哪怕真有一个空了的话
Lucia: Even if there's an empty one.
Jake:没电
Jake: No power.
Tasha: 那个支架
Tasha: That stand.
Tasha: 能不能把手电筒放上面会不会好点
Tasha: Can we put the flashlight on it? Would that be better?
Shure: 卧槽倍儿香
Shure: Whoa, smells great.
Tasha: 就不用举着了
Tasha: So we don't have to hold it.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Lucia: 把那个手机固定到云台或者什么上面
Lucia: Fix the phone on the gimbal or something.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Shure: 感觉对了
Shure: Feels right.
Lucia: 有有有有手机夹子或者啥的
Lucia: Do we have a phone clip or something?
Alice:我们家就老在阳台上烤肉吃
Alice: We always barbecue on the balcony at home.
Lucia: 这有个看起来有点像能夹手机的东西
Lucia: This looks like something that can hold a phone.
Jake:可以啊那我就觉得呢
Jake: Alright, then I think...
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Yeah, it works.
Lucia: 但我不太确定它具体是个啥这个
Lucia: But I'm not really sure what exactly this is.
Tasha: 没关系哈哈
Tasha: It's okay, haha.
Shure: 你行行行行
Shure: You got this, you got this.
Katrina: 哎可以了可以了
Katrina: Hey, that's good enough.
Jake:我在乡下
Jake: I'm in the countryside.
Katrina: 嘉玲可以听见吗
Katrina: Ka-Ling, can you hear us?
Katrina: 你你能共享屏幕给我们看一下吗
Katrina: Can you share your screen with us?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Katrina: 可以可以
Katrina: Alright, alright.
Jake:哈哈哈手机
Jake: Hahaha, the phone.
Lucia: 哈哈哈震动模式结束了
Lucia: Hahaha, the vibration mode is over.
Jake:哈哈关机了
Jake: Haha, it's turned off.
Lucia: 震动模式关机了
Lucia: The vibration mode is turned off.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你关机没电了是吧
Lucia: Hahaha, you turned it off because it ran out of battery, right?
Alice:也得熟了
Alice: It should be done by now.
Katrina: 它就是一个在一个Duo vivo
Katrina: It's just a Duo vivo...
Lucia: 这东西是干嘛的
Lucia: What does this thing do?
Jake:是吧对
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Katrina: 用Duo vivo进行那个确认检测的
Katrina: Using Duo vivo for verification and testing.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 这个是这里
Lucia: This is the place.
Shure: 我不行了
Shure: I can't do it anymore.
Lucia: 这是您之前用来想用来固定go Pro的吗
Lucia: Is this what you used to try and fix the GoPro with?
Katrina: 然后在上面改进进入改进的
Katrina: And then you made improvements on it.
Lucia: 还是干嘛
Lucia: Or what?
Jake:对是是这么回事
Jake: Yes, that's how it is.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:但是固定手机确实不太合适
Jake: But it's not really suitable for holding a phone.
Alice:一个大馋丫头
Alice: Such a little glutton.
Katrina: 是你那一篇就是
Katrina: It's that one article...
Lucia: 哦对手机带有一个那样
Lucia: Oh yeah, the phone has one like that.
Katrina: 嗯你不知道创新
Katrina: Uh, you know the innovation.
Alice:你吃你吃
Alice: Just eat, just eat.
Katrina: 就是你那个创新点
Katrina: It's that innovation of yours.
Lucia: 就是跟自拍杆一样那种纸
Lucia: It's like those selfie stick things.
Alice:你吃一下熟不熟
Alice: Try it and see if it's done.
Katrina: 被老师否定的那个吗
Katrina: The one the teacher rejected?
Jake:对加起来对
Jake: Yes, put it together.
Lucia: 那种夹子才行
Lucia: Only the clip kind works.
Katrina: 我那个那个就是现在还在做实验现在
Katrina: I'm still doing experiments right now.
Lucia: 这他用这边把手机夹坏了
Lucia: He broke his phone with this thing over here.
Lucia: 那咋整啊
Lucia: What should we do?
Katrina: 嗯那这篇呢
Katrina: Hmm, what about this part?
Katrina: 这篇能投什么
Katrina: What can we submit this to?
Lucia: 整个绳给他绑到上面吧
Lucia: Tie it up with a rope.
Katrina: 有老师带吗
Katrina: Is there a teacher guiding you?
Alice:熟吗那三二那个值吗
Alice: Are you familiar with that three-two value?
Jake:我我也来取材一下
Jake: Let me gather some materials too.
Katrina: 这些没有
Katrina: No, there's nothing here.
Katrina: 就自己写的
Katrina: I wrote them myself.
Shure: 这样还有这个
Shure: Like this, and also this.
Jake:考察一下
Jake: Let’s inspect it a bit.
Shure: 这方绝逼可以治
Shure: This method can definitely cure it.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Shure: 这个这也可以
Shure: This one, this can work too.
Lucia: 因为咱们的那个啥插板没那么长
Lucia: Because our power strip isn't that long.
Alice:有点带有点点生
Alice: It's a bit raw.
Jake:外边没有电哈
Jake: There's no power outside, right?
Alice:老板要不要尝一个
Alice: Boss, do you want to try one?
Jake:啊好了
Jake: Ah, okay.
Shure: 好了好了
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 快快快叫出来叫出来快快快
Shure: Quick, quick, call it out, call it out, quick.
Alice:哎呦呦我去
Alice: Oh my, oh my.
Jake:我去怎么吃
Jake: How do I eat this?
Alice:不行不行
Alice: No, no.
Jake:这个真
Jake: This really...
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What are you doing?
Jake:这边真的没电吗
Jake: Is there really no power here?
Katrina: 那你这个创新点
Katrina: So, this is your innovation point?
Shure: 我没没吐没吐
Shure: I didn't, didn't throw up.
Katrina: 是自己看论文然后想的吗找的吗
Katrina: Did you come up with it by reading papers?
Shure: 没吐我就
Shure: I didn't throw up, I just...
Lucia: 我不知道啊哈哈
Lucia: I don’t know, haha.
Lucia: 你看比如说时间什么的这些
Lucia: You see, for example, things like time.
Lucia: 到了应该就可以了吧
Lucia: It should be okay when the time's up, right?
Katrina: 那就是找那种机构帮你发是吧
Katrina: So, you’re asking some institution to help you publish it, right?
Katrina: 对这个我还没了解
Katrina: Yeah, I haven't looked into that yet.
Katrina: 到时候看吧
Katrina: I'll check it out later.
Alice:你你把你把芝麻给我呗
Alice: Can you give me the sesame seeds?
Katrina: 嗯然后你得你得稍微去了解一下
Katrina: Hmm, then you should learn a bit about it.
Shure: 撒点芝麻是吗
Shure: Sprinkle some sesame seeds, right?
Alice:芝麻跟辣椒面自己撒吧
Alice: Sprinkle the sesame seeds and chili powder yourself.
Katrina: 能不能赶上夏令营
Katrina: Can we make it in time for the summer camp?
Shure: 这个很咸
Shure: This is really salty.
Katrina: 然后然后
Katrina: And then...
Alice:这个已经很咸了
Alice: This is already very salty.
Katrina: 然后就是
Katrina: And then...
Alice:你不管了
Alice: Don't worry about it.
Katrina: 如果他们给你报那个呃EI会议的名字
Katrina: If they give you the name of the EI conference...
Jake:哎这不是插座吗
Jake: Hey, isn't this a socket?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my God.
Katrina: 你最好也去查一下哈
Katrina: You'd better check it out too.
Jake:这不是插座吗卧槽
Jake: Isn't this a socket, damn it.
Shure: 我操快快快
Shure: Oh crap, quick, quick!
Katrina: 因为有的那个机构
Katrina: Because some institutions...
Alice:拿出来一个
Alice: Take one out.
Shure: 拿出来一个
Shure: Take one out.
Shure: 我快快瞎了都
Shure: I'm almost blind.
Katrina: 他给的会议不是特别好
Katrina: The conferences they give are not very good.
Alice:这个烤会吧再
Alice: Let's grill this a bit more.
Katrina: 你这个是做什么的呀
Katrina: What is this for?
Shure: 没问题应该
Shure: Should be no problem.
Jake:外边有插座
Jake: There's a socket outside.
Jake:整半天外边有插座
Jake: Spent all this time, and there's a socket outside.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 就现在这个论文
Katrina: About this paper now...
Lucia: 哦外面有插座
Lucia: Oh, there's a socket outside.
Shure: 呀
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 这可以这真真可以
Shure: This is good, really good.
Shure: 你看一点血没有
Shure: Look, there's no blood at all.
Lucia:比较嫩
Lucia: It's quite tender.
Shure: 我爱吃嫩的
Shure: I love eating it tender.
Katrina: 这是你当时是谁给你的idea和题目啊
Katrina: Who gave you the idea and topic at that time?
Alice:但是我们这一会加生一会加熟的好吗
Alice: But we keep adding raw and cooked at the same time, okay?
Alice:唉算了
Alice: Ah, forget it.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Just leave it like this.
Shure: 哎呀妈呀
Shure: Oh my God.
Katrina: 这个是之前上课
Katrina: This is from the previous class...
Shure: 他俩
Shure: They both...
Shure: 他最开始最后一下和最最开始一下
Shure: His first and last hit, and the very first hit.
Katrina: 上课的时候学到过
Katrina: Learned this in class.
Katrina: 然后后面就自己查了下
Katrina: Then I looked it up myself.
Shure: 是不是都是我们加的
Shure: Did we add all of those?
Shure: 所以他一直在这个
Shure: So he's always been in this...
Katrina: 哦你现在写完了吗
Katrina: Oh, are you done writing now?
Alice:随便无所谓
Alice: Whatever, it doesn't matter.
Katrina: 你这个有跑实验吗
Katrina: Did you run the experiment?
Katrina: 有好就是快要写完了
Katrina: Yes, just about finished.
Katrina: 都看看你往下看
Katrina: Let's all take a look, keep going.
Katrina: 肯定还是自己选的
Katrina: It must still be my own choice.
Alice:快来个灯吧
Alice: Hurry, get a light.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Alice:我要瞎了家人
Alice: I'm going blind, guys.
Katrina: 肯定还是有点sure
Katrina: There's still a bit of sure.
Katrina: 嗯你对YOLO V5模型有改进吗
Katrina: Have you made any improvements to the YOLO V5 model?
Lucia: 哎小心啊
Lucia: Hey, be careful.
Lucia: 吓我一跳
Lucia: You scared me.
Katrina: 改进了什么
Katrina: What did you improve?
Lucia: 哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Katrina: 加了它的模块吗
Katrina: Did you add its module?
Shure: 我操有灯了有灯了
Shure: Wow, there's light now, there's light.
Lucia: 这刀板尽量不要放在外面
Lucia: Try not to leave the knife board out.
Lucia: 别哪个同学碰着掉下来
Lucia: Someone might knock it over.
Jake:哎还得是得彩排一次
Jake: Hey, we need to rehearse once.
Lucia: 就把人戳上了
Lucia: It might poke someone.
Shure: 对所有的都得彩排
Shure: Yeah, we need to rehearse everything.
Shure: 不然话到时候啥都
Shure: Otherwise, everything will...
Jake:对你们表演一般怎么个彩排法
Jake: So, how do you guys usually rehearse your performances?
Katrina: 哪个性能比别的模型要好呀
Katrina: Which performance is better than the others?
Jake:不用彩排
Jake: No need to rehearse.
Katrina: 准确率吗
Katrina: Accuracy?
Lucia: 啊刚好那个锅洗好了
Lucia: Ah, just finished washing that pot.
Jake:试一试一次拿倒
Jake: Just try it once and you're good.
Shure: 对就是对
Shure: Yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 如果要弄什么的话
Lucia: If you're going to do something...
Shure: 挑两手试一下
Shure: Try it a couple of times.
Shure: 就把那个音色都调对了就OK
Shure: Just get the tone right and it's okay.
Shure: 哎别别扣上他那挺埋汰的
Shure: Hey, don't cover it, it's pretty dirty.
Shure: 那盖是脏的
Shure: That lid is dirty.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: 好香啊
Lucia: Smells so good.
Shure: 加点大自然的味道
Shure: Add a bit of nature's scent.
Katrina: 嗯看看
Katrina: Hmm, let’s see.
Katrina: 那就是这个论文你是要投是吧
Katrina: So, you’re planning to submit this paper, right?
Alice:再能俩近点吗
Alice: Can it get a bit closer?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Shure: 应该撩不着
Shure: Shouldn't be a problem.
Katrina: 然后那一篇论文就
Katrina: And then that paper...
Katrina: 实验进展到哪一步了
Katrina: How far has the experiment progressed?
Lucia: 这个擦一下是吗
Lucia: Should I wipe this?
Shure: 太牛逼了
Shure: That's awesome.
Katrina: 这个我
Katrina: This, I...
Katrina: 我感觉夏宁宁
Katrina: I feel like Xia Ningning...
Lucia: 嗯纸了呀在这
Lucia: Hmm, the paper is here.
Shure: 这头让他抬抬
Shure: Lift his head a bit.
Jake:我靠确实牛逼
Jake: Wow, that's really amazing.
Katrina: 夏宁宁之前播出去的那个
Katrina: The one Xia Ningning broadcasted earlier...
Katrina: 他可能你说手上这个吗
Katrina: Are you talking about this one in hand?
Jake:就拿石头买卖
Jake: Just buy and sell rocks.
Lucia: 实测
Lucia: Tested it.
Lucia: 我们从一开始就应该买个厨房纸的
Lucia: We should've bought kitchen paper from the start.
Katrina: 还是说那个晚安的那个
Katrina: Or the goodnight one?
Katrina: 我说那一篇嗯
Katrina: I meant that one, hmm.
Katrina: 你那个老师是教授吗
Katrina: Is your teacher a professor?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Katrina: 副教授
Katrina: Associate professor.
Lucia: 厨房纸的话一张就擦干了
Lucia: With kitchen paper, one sheet is enough to clean.
Jake:确实牛逼
Jake: Truly amazing.
Katrina: 嗯我想想可以也
Katrina: Hmm, let me think, yeah, it works too.
Lucia: 嗯等会我们把这个奶油打一下
Lucia: Hmm, let's whip this cream later.
Jake:这光一打确实牛逼的多
Jake: The lighting makes it look much better.
Katrina: 也可以
Katrina: That works too.
Alice:好手机扔一边吧
Alice: Alright, put your phone aside.
Lucia: 好的就OK了
Lucia: Okay, that's fine.
Katrina: 嗯那你现在的idea和创新点有确定吗
Katrina: Hmm, have you confirmed your ideas and innovations?
Jake:来师傅
Jake: Come on, master.
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What?
Jake:两位师傅来
Jake: Both masters, come here.
Shure: 一人一人摆拍一下先
Shure: Let’s take turns posing for a photo first.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Jake:摆拍摆拍
Jake: Pose, pose.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:挺厉害
Jake: Pretty impressive.
Shure: 来吃饭好了
Shure: Let's eat.
Jake:来 2号师傅
Jake: Come on, Chef No. 2.
Katrina: 嗯没事
Katrina: Mm, it's fine.
Lucia: 哦耶
Lucia: Oh yeah.
Jake:你给他摆一摆
Jake: Set it up for him.
Katrina: 那这样就好写了
Katrina: This makes it easier to write.
Katrina: 只要你那个整体的思路
Katrina: As long as you have the overall idea.
Shure: 快来吃饭喽
Shure: Hurry up and eat.
Lucia: 也行那我们一会回来再打他
Lucia: Alright, we can come back and deal with him later.
Katrina: 然后包括老师也认可你的idea
Katrina: Plus, the teacher agrees with your idea.
Alice:就熟了两块水咋吃
Alice: The water is cooked, how do we eat it?
Lucia: 行可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 然后你就可以把它包装成一个
Katrina: Then you can package it into a...
Lucia: 我看一眼啊可以
Lucia: Let me take a look, alright.
Shure: 吃饭吃饭
Shure: Let's eat, let's eat.
Shure: 凉了真凉了
Shure: It's really getting cold.
Katrina: 呃项目经历
Katrina: Uh, project experience.
Jake:哈哈哈刚烤上
Jake: Hahaha, just put it on the grill.
Katrina: 然后套词的时候也好说就
Katrina: And then it's easier to explain during the interview.
Lucia: 边上再弄好了
Lucia: Fix it up on the side.
Shure: 吃饭吃饭
Shure: Let's eat, let's eat.
Katrina: 毕竟你是自己做的
Katrina: After all, you made it yourself.
Katrina: 应该会就是回答问题会比较流利
Katrina: You should be able to answer questions more fluently.
Jake:刚烤上一分钟就凉了
Jake: Just grilled for a minute and it's cold already.
Shure: 快快快不然话凉了凉了真凉了
Shure: Hurry, hurry, or it'll really get cold.
Katrina: 那就还行
Katrina: That's alright.
Katrina: 那个是做什么的呀呃
Katrina: What was that for, uh...
Jake:完了完了
Jake: Done, done.
Lucia: 来了来了
Lucia: Coming, coming.
Shure: 必须得整瓶啤啤
Shure: We need a whole bottle of beer.
Katrina: 你说你介绍一下
Katrina: Explain it a bit.
Katrina: 刚刚那个是做什么的
Katrina: What was that for?
Katrina: 哪一个呀
Katrina: Which one?
Katrina: 就是那个没投出去的那个
Katrina: The one that wasn't submitted.
Katrina: 可是我实验还没考出来
Katrina: But my experiment hasn't been tested yet.
Shure: 嗯呐不会了今天
Shure: Hmm, no more today.
Katrina: 我也不知道效果怎么样啊
Katrina: I don't know how effective it is.
Katrina: 那你就是先说前面三部分吧
Katrina: How about you start with the first three parts?
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 前面三个就是你要解决一个什么问题
Katrina: The first three are about solving a problem.
Katrina: 就是有的老师坐在下面的评委老师
Katrina: Some of the judges sitting below
Katrina: 他不一定懂你
Katrina: might not understand you.
Katrina: 这个区就是领域
Katrina: This field is specialized.
Shure: 人都到齐
Shure: Everyone's here.
Shure: 开香槟
Shure: Open the champagne.
Katrina: 所以你要就是相当于你
Katrina: So you need to...
Shure: 先吃吧真的太要凉了
Shure: Let's eat first, it's getting cold.
Katrina: 相当于你去做销售一样
Katrina: It's like you're selling something.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Shure: 你们赶紧拿两个筷子快吃
Shure: Hurry and grab some chopsticks and eat.
Katrina: 你要通俗的
Katrina: Make it simple.
Jake:哎来拿一串
Jake: Hey, grab a skewer.
Katrina: 去流利的介绍你做的这个东西
Katrina: and introduce what you've done fluently.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Shure: 就是再拿一个小刀什么的吧
Shure: Maybe grab a small knife or something.
Katrina: 让别人能懂
Katrina: So others can understand.
Shure: 因为这个牌好像不是能一人一个的
Shure: This brand can't be given one per person.
Katrina: 然后并且显得很高级
Katrina: And make it look high-end.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 正好那个
Shure: Just right, that...
Jake:哦哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake:就总共三个是吧
Jake: So there are three in total?
Katrina: 你可以先跟我们就不用那么简洁的讲
Katrina: You can first explain to us in detail.
Shure: 一二现在这顶上几个
Shure: One, two, now how many on top?
Jake:是是吗
Jake: Is it?
Jake:这这这有你啊
Jake: This, this, do you see?
Katrina: 就是详细的讲一下
Katrina: Just explain it in detail.
Lucia: 这这这个是第三个吗
Lucia: Is this the third one?
Jake:这啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake:你你你看看吧我咱整不明白这啥
Jake: Look, we can't figure this out.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 我这外面确实挺冷的
Lucia: It's really cold outside.
Katrina: 就是第一个
Katrina: This is the first one.
Shure: 卧槽这可以
Shure: Wow, this is good.
Lucia: 烤串得赶快吃
Lucia: Gotta eat the skewers quickly.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 反正第一个就是提高它的性能
Katrina: Anyway, the first thing is to improve its performance
Lucia: 大家这么谦让我就先吃了
Lucia: Since everyone is being so polite, I'll start eating
Katrina: 就是把
Katrina: Just
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 我去哈哈哈
Lucia: I'm going, hahaha
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Katrina: 就是在传统的方法上
Katrina: It's based on traditional methods
Lucia: 啊那走
Lucia: Ah, let's go
Lucia: 我们再搬几个筷子出来
Lucia: Let's bring out a few more pairs of chopsticks
Shure: 都可以了
Shure: That works
Alice:这两样可以
Alice: These two are fine
Jake:好咱咱咱确实要整点刀
Jake: Alright, we really need to get some knives
Katrina: 把它引入到在一个有限域下
Katrina: Introduce it within a limited domain
Alice:给我留一个肥一点的谢谢
Alice: Save me a fattier piece, thank you
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This
Katrina: 然后可以
Katrina: Then it can
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Katrina: 哎呀我不知道我自己
Katrina: Oh, I don't know myself
Jake:除了菜刀的一些刀
Jake: Besides kitchen knives, some other knives
Shure: 那你把它一直放
Shure: Then you keep it there
Shure: 放在那边围着
Shure: Keep it over there, surrounding
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Katrina: 那你那个呃
Katrina: And that, uh
Lucia: 问题是现在这也没别的刀啊
Lucia: The problem is there aren't any other knives
Katrina: 就是也没有写东西
Katrina: There also isn't anything written
Alice:这个不能是总是我的吧
Alice: This can't always be mine, right?
Katrina: 所以你也不能展示是吧
Katrina: So you can't show it, right?
Alice:这不是把刀切了吗
Alice: Didn't we already cut with the knife?
Katrina: 作业呢还没写
Katrina: The homework isn't done yet
Alice:这个还没太熟呢
Alice: This isn't fully cooked yet
Lucia: 这也没别的刀啊
Lucia: There aren't any other knives either
Alice:搁这吧再烤会
Alice: Let's put it here and roast a bit more
Katrina: 嗯那你这学期还有比赛吗
Katrina: Hmm, do you have any more competitions this semester?
Lucia: 不是这也没别的筷子
Lucia: But there aren't any other chopsticks either
Katrina: 没有那就是忙这两篇论文是吧
Katrina: No, just busy with these two papers, right?
Jake:啊筷子也没了
Jake: Ah, no more chopsticks
Lucia: 呀
Lucia: Yeah
Katrina: 然后你们这学期的专业必修课还多吗
Katrina: And do you still have a lot of required courses this semester?
Shure: 然后进去拿刀
Shure: Then go inside and get the knife.
Lucia: 哦对对对
Lucia: Oh right, right.
Shure: 拿个小刀
Shure: Get a small knife.
Katrina: 必修课不多
Katrina: There aren't many required courses.
Katrina: 就只有两个
Katrina: Just two.
Jake:小刀没有小刀
Jake: No small knife, no small knife.
Shure: 小刀对能切羊排的餐刀
Shure: A small knife, like a steak knife for cutting lamb chops.
Katrina: 啊那你现在机事复习到哪一步了
Katrina: Ah, so how far are you in your exam review?
Shure: 最好是餐刀
Shure: A steak knife would be best.
Shure: 不要不行不行
Shure: No, no, that won't do.
Jake:没有
Jake: We don't have any.
Katrina: 机事机事
Katrina: Exam, exam.
Alice:那啥能搁上来吧
Alice: Can you put it here?
Katrina: 这这这两种没看
Katrina: These two things, I haven't looked at them.
Alice:把那鸡翅搁来吧
Alice: Put the chicken wings here.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:那鸡翅太慢了
Alice: The chicken wings are too slow.
Katrina: 嗯嗯那就是这篇论文
Katrina: Hmm, so it's this paper.
Jake:吃
Jake: Eat.
Alice:慢慢弄吧
Alice: Take your time.
Katrina: 你预计能什么时候写完
Katrina: When do you expect to finish writing?
Jake:我先把刀送过去
Jake: I'll send the knife over first.
Katrina: 就屏幕共享的这个
Katrina: The one we're screen sharing.
Shure: 先烤联快的给大家喂上行吧
Jake:没有小刀
Jake: No small knife.
Katrina: 这这周末前吗
Katrina: By the end of this weekend?
Shure: 我操整吧那就
Shure: Oh well, let's do it then.
Jake:没有小刀
Jake: No small knife.
Jake:你你给我个镜头
Jake: Give me a shot.
Katrina: OK然后那个实验呢
Katrina: OK, and what about the experiment?
Shure: 啊哈哈哈哈
Shure: Ahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 他加入一件啊
Lucia: He added one.
Katrina: 哦下周
Katrina: Oh, next week.
Katrina: 那那那个实验呢
Katrina: And what about that experiment?
Katrina: 就是就不确定是吧
Katrina: So it's still uncertain, right?
Lucia: 大家看一下
Lucia: Everyone, take a look.
Katrina: 嗯但是那也还好
Katrina: Hmm, but that's still fine.
Jake:我来切了
Jake: I'll cut it.
Katrina: 就是你下周把这嗯
Katrina: So, next week you...
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 就差不多4月底吧
Katrina: Around the end of April
Katrina: 就5月前把这篇论文给投出去
Katrina: We should submit this paper before May
Alice:这都会掉不回
Alice: This won't fall back
Katrina: 然后然后5月份的时候
Katrina: And then in May
Jake:好我拿点刀下来
Jake: Okay, I'll get some knives
Katrina: 重心就是
Katrina: The focus is
Katrina: 其实也就两件事
Katrina: Actually, just two things
Katrina: 一个是复习
Katrina: One is reviewing
Katrina: 一个就是忙
Katrina: The other is busy
Katrina: 那个实验嘛
Katrina: With the experiment
Katrina: 其实还是忙的过来的
Katrina: Actually, it's manageable
Shure: 这真应该弄个帘子
Shure: We really should get a curtain
Shure: 确实不好翻
Shure: It's hard to flip
Katrina: 嗯然后我就大概明白了
Katrina: Hmm, then I roughly understand
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And then
Katrina: 嗯到时候我帮你改简历的话
Katrina: Hmm, if I help you revise your resume
Lucia: 那现在有几个筷子呀
Lucia: How many chopsticks do we have now?
Shure: 我草真会掉
Shure: Damn, it will really fall
Lucia: 呃就就就一个吗那就12
Lucia: Uh, just one? Then it's 12
Katrina: 这两天先帮你改这篇文章的
Katrina: I'll help you revise this article in the next two days
Katrina: 然后那个的话还是先空着
Katrina: And then leave that one for now
Shure: 这小子这可咋整我草啊
Shure: What to do with this guy, damn
Katrina: 然后你也要大概组织一下语言哈
Katrina: Then you need to organize your words a bit
Lucia: 34
Katrina: 然后其他的我没什么问题
Katrina: And I don't have any other questions
Lucia: 56
Katrina: 你问问学长有没有什么建议
Katrina: Ask the senior if they have any suggestions
Shure: 不行就这个吧
Shure: If not, let's go with this
Shure: 这个涮涮凑合用一下
Shure: We can make do with this
Lucia: 好就这样
Lucia: Alright, let's do it
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
Lucia: wait a
Katrina: 那个雨轩的帮我再总结一下
Katrina: Can you summarize what Yuxuan said for me?
Katrina: 我刚刚在接电话
Katrina: I was on the phone just now
Jake:还有别的菜刀吗
Jake: Are there any other knives?
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Ah
Katrina: 嗯没事
Katrina: Hmm, it's okay
Shure: 快快快帮他下
Shure: Quick, quick, help him out
Katrina: 就是我我这边看到的就是他这学期
Katrina: So what I saw is that this semester
Shure: 快帮他下
Shure: Quick, help him down.
Jake:还有别的菜刀吗
Jake: Do we have any other kitchen knives?
Katrina: 嗯没有比赛
Katrina: Um, no competition.
Jake:就一个菜刀吗
Jake: Just one kitchen knife?
Katrina: 然后专业必修课也比较少
Katrina: And there are also fewer required courses.
Katrina: 然后就是复习加上手上这两篇论文
Katrina: And then it's just reviewing and working on these two papers.
Shure: 哎都是菜刀能算啊
Shure: Hey, all kitchen knives count.
Alice:看来拿个啥东西
Alice: Seems like grabbing something.
Shure: 那有剪子
Shure: There's scissors.
Lucia: 压一下什么
Lucia: Press something down.
Katrina: 然后他现在展示的这一篇论文呢
Katrina: And the paper he's presenting now,
Shure: 那剪子是可以剪肉
Shure: Those scissors can cut meat.
Katrina: 是自己写的
Katrina: He wrote it himself.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 就是一个可能本科做的一个项目
Katrina: It might be a project he did as an undergrad.
Katrina: 然后打算自己去投一篇EI
Katrina: Then he plans to submit it to EI on his own.
Katrina: 就是没有老师带的
Katrina: Without a teacher's guidance.
Katrina: 然后在下周前估计能写完
Katrina: And he expects to finish it by next week.
Lucia: 这给他往里塞点
Lucia: Stuff it in for him.
Shure: 最后还是不行
Shure: In the end, it still doesn't work.
Shure: 还是得用上这
Shure: Still have to use this.
Katrina: 然后第二个就是他老师带
Katrina: And the second one is guided by his teacher.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 他那个创新点
Katrina: His innovation point.
Shure: 个拿那个不是烤那个肉嘛
Shure: Take that to grill the meat.
Alice:往这边转一点点
Alice: Turn it a bit this way.
Katrina: 前一段时间不是被否定了吗
Katrina: Was rejected a while ago.
Katrina: 然后实验还在跑
Katrina: But the experiment is still ongoing.
Jake:鸡翅烤哦还得用这个
Jake: Oh, you still need this to grill the chicken wings.
Katrina: 但是他的创新点
Katrina: But his innovation point.
Lucia: 没事我吃完不太好
Lucia: It's okay, I don't feel too well after eating.
Shure: 然后那个拿拿一个那个卫生的那个
Shure: Then take that sanitary thing.
Katrina: 和那个总体的实验方法是确定的
Katrina: And the overall experimental method is confirmed.
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Alright.
Katrina: 所以就这两个
Katrina: So it's just these two.
Lucia: 棒棒这筷子再拿回去
Lucia: Great, take the chopsticks back.
Shure: 湿巾湿巾湿巾就在那
Shure: Wet wipes, wet wipes, right there.
Katrina: 然后我给他的建议就是忙这两篇论文
Katrina: And my advice to him is to focus on these two papers.
Katrina: 5月 5月前忙完这篇论文
Katrina: Finish this paper by May.
Katrina: 然后之后5月就是要忙他的复习
Katrina: And then in May, he will be busy with his review.
Katrina: 和那一篇
Katrina: And that paper.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Katrina: 两个县城并行
Katrina: Two county towns running parallel.
Katrina: 我觉得还是能够忙得过来的
Katrina: I think it's still manageable.
Lucia: 外面放了6双
Lucia: There are 6 pairs outside.
Lucia: 这几双筷子先放这
Lucia: Let's put these chopsticks here first.
Katrina: 然后我主要就是知道一下
Katrina: And I just need to know.
Lucia: 呃放放这吧
Lucia: Uh, let's put them here.
Katrina: 他论文的大概内容和档次就行
Katrina: The general content and level of his paper.
Lucia: 一会要是需要用再拿
Lucia: We can take them if we need later.
Lucia: 嗯我刚才吃的
Lucia: Hmm, I just ate.
Katrina: 到时候看
Katrina: We'll see then.
Tasha: 哇切的好平整呀
Tasha: Wow, you cut it so evenly.
Katrina: 如果是他自己投机构的话
Katrina: If he's submitting to an institution himself.
Katrina: 可能那边也要对接一下
Katrina: He might need to coordinate there too.
Jake:哎呀好烫
Jake: Oh, it's so hot.
Katrina: 跟那个你要投什么会议
Katrina: With whatever conference you're submitting to.
Jake:真的好烫
Jake: It's really hot.
Katrina: 可能那边也会有自己的格式吧
Katrina: They might have their own format too.
Tasha: 烫
Tasha: Hot.
Katrina: 然后你就
Katrina: And then you just.
Katrina: 或者是你先从Wechat上随便找一个模板
Katrina: Or you can just find a template from WeChat.
Jake:是挺烫
Jake: It is quite hot.
Katrina: 往里放就行了
Katrina: And put it in.
Katrina: 你可以找那个计算机学报的
Katrina: You can find the one for the Journal of Computer Science.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina: 计算机学报的那个模板
Katrina: The template for the Journal of Computer Science.
Katrina: 如果你要写中文版的话
Katrina: If you are writing in Chinese.
Katrina: 如果你写英文的话
Katrina: If you are writing in English.
Jake:还能补救吗
Jake: Can it still be saved?
Katrina: 随便找一个什么AC啊或者是
Katrina: Just find any AC or something.
Jake:没办法了
Jake: No way.
Tasha: 没办法没关系
Tasha: No way, it's okay.
Shure: 办法
Shure: Way.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Tasha: 你等会再切通
Tasha: You can cut it later.
Jake:那没关系
Jake: That's okay.
Jake:他放下面一层嘛对吧
Jake: Put it on the lower layer, right?
Katrina: 嗯那等他把这个主题全部写完
Katrina: Yeah, then wait until he finishes writing the whole theme.
Katrina: 再跳格式吧
Katrina: Let's skip the format.
Katrina: 嗯那其他我没啥问题
Katrina: Hmm, I don't have any other issues.
Jake:碘伏准备哎
Jake: Prepare the iodine.
Katrina: 我现在大概了解了他的那个经历
Katrina: Now I roughly understand his experience.
Jake:哎
Jake: Okay.
Jake:对不起了碘伏
Jake: Sorry, iodine.
Jake:用不上你了
Jake: We won't need you anymore.
Katrina: 嗯好
Katrina: Alright.
Katrina: 我现在明白
Katrina: I understand now.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Katrina: 就没啥问题
Katrina: There are no issues.
Katrina: 你你有什么问题要问我们吗
Katrina: Do you have any questions for us?
Jake:你切的好薄呀
Jake: You cut it so thin.
Katrina: 就是我大概什么时候去透视啊就是
Katrina: When do I get to do the X-ray?
Lucia: 我靠
Lucia: Oh my god.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:这是个锅底
Jake: This is the base.
Lucia: 我不知道这一层这一层要干嘛呀
Lucia: I don't know what to do with this layer.
Jake:这是个锅底是吧
Jake: This is the base, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Katrina: 你那个第二篇论文的实验
Katrina: Your second paper experiment...
Shure: 翻一下吧
Shure: Flip it over.
Jake:尝尝吧啊不是
Jake: Try it, I mean...
Shure: 翻一下吧
Shure: Flip it over.
Katrina: 做到哪一步了
Katrina: How far did you get?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina: 就是模型在跑吗
Katrina: Is the model running?
Katrina: 数据集是自己弄的
Katrina: Did you create the dataset yourself?
Katrina: 模型在跑
Katrina: The model is running.
Alice:姐的技术
Alice: My skills.
Lucia: 谢谢好吧
Lucia: Thank you, alright.
Jake:好吃吗好吧
Jake: Is it tasty? Alright.
Alice:你放心姐是天台战神
Alice: Don't worry, I'm the rooftop battle god.
Shure: 好哎呀
Shure: Okay, wow.
Jake:那我们就扒了吃了吧
Jake: Then let's peel it and eat it.
Lucia: 那我们就扒了吃了吧挺好吃吃了
Lucia: Then let's peel it and eat it, it's quite good, let's eat.
Shure: 简直天才战神
Shure: Simply a genius battle god.
Jake:挺好吃挺好吃
Jake: Quite tasty, quite tasty.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:吃了哈哈
Jake: Eat it, haha.
Shure: 我给姐升高一点好吧
Shure: I'll raise it a bit for you, okay?
Tasha: 糖醋伯爵
Tasha: Sweet and sour Earl.
Jake:好两两两
Jake: Alright, two, two, two.
Katrina: 嗯然后到时候我帮你把简历弄一下
Katrina: Yeah, and then I'll help you with the resume later.
Jake:哎三三也行
Jake: Oh, three, three works too.
Jake:我试试我来测一测
Jake: Let me try, I'll measure it.
Katrina: 就行了
Katrina: That's fine.
Jake:放心放心
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:我测一测
Jake: I'll measure it.
Jake:我我测一测我测一测
Jake: I'll measure it, I'll measure it.
Jake:哎哎哎好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Tasha: 您测您测
Tasha: Go ahead and measure.
Jake:我先测一测
Jake: Let me measure first.
Katrina: 那还有其他的
Katrina: Are there any other things?
Tasha: 好您测
Tasha: Alright, you measure.
Katrina: 还有啥问题不
Katrina: Anything else?
Lucia: 你搓的时候把这底下再吃点
Lucia: When you rub, eat a bit from the bottom.
Lucia: 哈哈哈不着急不着急
Lucia: Hahaha, no rush, no rush.
Jake:哈哈哈那我慢慢测哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, then I'll measure slowly, hahaha.
Katrina: 没有什么了
Katrina: Nothing else.
Katrina: 嗯有什么我到时候再去问吧
Katrina: If there's anything, I'll ask later.
Katrina: 好的好的
Katrina: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 先到这吧
Katrina: Let's stop here.
Katrina: 好嗯
Katrina: Okay, yeah.
Katrina: 拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye, bye.
Katrina: 非常再见
Katrina: See you very soon.
Katrina: 没事没事
Katrina: No worries.
Tasha: 2层咱们就加入芒果
Tasha: For the second layer, we'll add mango.
Jake:这两层嘛
Jake: These two layers?
Jake:这三层嘛
Jake: These three layers?
Tasha: 好那你就切三层
Tasha: Alright, then you cut three layers.
Jake:我我再试一下
Jake: Let me try again.
Lucia: 不是你切着切着咱们把这吃完了
Lucia: No, as you cut, we'll finish eating it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: OK了
Shure: Okay, done.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 这些应该都熟了吧
Shure: These should all be cooked, right?
Lucia: 小心手
Lucia: Careful with your hand.
Shure: 打个光看一眼
Shure: Shine a light to check it out.
Katrina: 这是在做什么
Katrina: What are we doing here?
Jake:再切蛋糕再分层
Jake: Cutting the cake again and adding layers.
Katrina: 切蛋糕哇
Katrina: Cutting the cake, wow.
Shure: 还没有
Shure: Not yet.
Alice:再加一点
Alice: Add a little more.
Lucia: 好耶
Lucia: Yay!
Jake:再来一层
Jake: Another layer.
Shure: 呢这个应该差不多了吧
Shure: This should be about right, right?
Lucia: 这真的还够再切一层吗
Lucia: Is there really enough to cut another layer?
Tasha: 你看这一层多厚啊
Tasha: Look how thick this layer is.
Shure: 可以
Shure: It’s fine.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Go ahead.
Lucia: 再再切太薄了
Lucia: Cutting it again will make it too thin.
Lucia: 别别别又给最后
Lucia: No, no, leave it for the last.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Lucia: 我们做出来一个pancake是吧哈哈
Lucia: We ended up making a pancake, right? Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, it's fine.
Katrina: 哈可以吗
Katrina: Ha, really?
Jake:吗可以
Jake: Yeah, it's fine.
Shure: 真来吃吧
Shure: Let's really eat it.
Jake:好可以吧
Jake: Alright, let's do it.
Shure: 再不吃真凉了
Shure: If we don’t eat now, it’ll get cold.
Jake:姚老板这么自信肯定能切好
Jake: Jack is so confident, he can definitely cut it well.
Lucia: 杨老板这么自信肯定能签好
Katrina: 可
Katrina: Sure.
Jake:等一下我再测一下
Jake: Wait a second, let me measure it again.
Jake:这可以吧
Jake: This should be fine.
Shure: 没问题来吧来吧
Shure: No problem, go ahead.
Lucia: 我不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你看你得问
Lucia: You see, you have to ask.
Alice:我要肥一点
Alice: I want a thicker piece.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 你过来
Tasha: Come over here.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: wow i'm coming back
Katrina: Wow, I'm coming back.
Alice:今晚我来烤吧
Alice: I'll do the grilling tonight.
Jake:我怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with me?
Tasha: 你看这个怎么了
Tasha: Look at this, what's wrong with it?
Shure: 我来吧
Shure: Let me do it.
Jake:啊我我的几号
Jake: Ah, what number am I?
Lucia: 我的喜好
Lucia: My preference.
Jake:我的4号
Jake: I'm number 4.
Lucia: 往里弄一点
Lucia: Move it a bit inside.
Lucia: 你的最后最边角的这个怎么就这么点
Lucia: Why is your last piece so small?
Shure: 来来子轩
Shure: Come on, Zixuan.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Alice:哇
Alice: Wow.
Shure: 不不不呸
Shure: No, no, no, ptooey.
Lucia: 不是你不是再分配过了吗
Lucia: Didn't you redistribute it?
Alice:都什么
Alice: What are all these?
Katrina: 叫什么哈哈尝尝是吗
Katrina: What's this? Haha, want to try it?
Shure: 雨轩雨轩雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan, Yuxuan, Yuxuan.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这也太离谱了吧
Lucia: Hahaha, this is so ridiculous.
Jake:不是不是客观
Jake: No, no, it's objective.
Jake:不是客观规律吗
Jake: Isn't it an objective rule?
Shure: 先吃先吃咱
Shure: Let's eat first.
Katrina: 给你拍照
Katrina: Let me take a picture for you.
Shure: 偷偷吃不等他们了
Shure: Sneak a bite without them.
Jake:不是客观规律吗
Jake: Isn't it an objective rule?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 叫我半天不来吃
Shure: Calling me all this time, not eating.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈这叉子
Lucia: Hahahaha, this fork.
Katrina: 他们在里面可
Katrina: They are inside...
Shure: 啊也不是因为要烤
Shure: Ah, it's not because it needs to be grilled.
Lucia: 哎呀你看这个好多呀
Lucia: Wow, look at this, so much!
Shure: 应该就不会喝多了
Shure: Shouldn't drink too much now.
Lucia: 哎这个怎么这么过分
Lucia: Hey, why is this so outrageous?
Lucia: 没事没事这个预期效果和实际
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, the expected result and the actual...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你这已经切开了一部分了好吗
Lucia: You've already cut a part of it, right?
Jake:哈哈哈剪刀在这个左边
Jake: Hahaha, the scissors are on the left.
Shure: 剪刀呢
Shure: Where are the scissors?
Jake:水水是左边
Jake: The water is on the left.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 不是你底下那点切开了一些了
Lucia: Didn't you cut some of it underneath?
Lucia: 在他那里面随便加点啥他就两种风味
Lucia: If you add anything to it, he’ll get two flavors.
Lucia: 一半是不是我瞎说的你干嘛
Lucia: Am I just making things up? What are you doing?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Jake:哈我觉得合理
Jake: Haha, I think it's reasonable.
Alice:快来吃吧
Alice: Come and eat quickly.
Alice:真的熟了
Alice: It's really done.
Shure: 来
Shure: Coming.
Lucia: 哇这个
Lucia: Wow, this.
Lucia: 擦干了是吧
Lucia: It's dry, right?
Shure: 我靠你直接一块全啃了是吧
Shure: Wow, did you just gnaw on the whole piece?
Lucia: 我再摸摸
Lucia: Let me touch it again.
Lucia: 我我反正我刚擦
Lucia: I just wiped it anyway.
Alice:就可以拿下来了
Alice: You can take it off now.
Lucia: 我觉得是干了
Lucia: I think it's dry.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 干了我还不在行行行
Lucia: If it's dry, I'm not good at it, alright.
Katrina: 嗯好好吃
Katrina: Hmm, it's so delicious.
Alice:怎么样
Alice: How is it?
Katrina: 忒香了
Katrina: It's super fragrant.
Lucia: 你觉得要两层奶油还是一层
Lucia: Do you think we need two layers of cream or one?
Jake:杨森我又来了
Jake: I'm back, Jason.
Shure: 好吃的翘脚脚了是吗
Shure: Is it so good that you lifted your feet?
Lucia: 奶油两层
Lucia: Two layers of cream.
Lucia: 我有喜乐
Lucia: I'm happy.
Jake:我又行了我觉得
Jake: I think I did well again.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 我觉得你有喜欢
Lucia: I think you like it.
Shure: 这个可以拿下来是吗
Shure: Can we take this off?
Alice:这是生的
Alice: This is raw.
Shure: 这是生的那个
Shure: This one is raw.
Alice:那个那个那个
Alice: That one, that one.
Shure: 这几个
Shure: These ones.
Alice:不是这俩都是生的
Alice: No, these two are raw.
Lucia: 偷偷用嘴
Lucia: Sneak a bite.
Lucia: 哈哈没事没事
Lucia: Haha, it's okay, it's okay.
Alice:他们怎么不过来呢
Alice: Why aren't they coming?
Lucia: 两层奶油的话是用多少
Lucia: How much cream do we use for two layers?
Shure: 谁知道呢
Shure: Who knows?
Lucia: 这个呀
Lucia: This one?
Tasha: 你倒倒倒2
Tasha: Pour it, pour it, pour it.
Tasha: 嗯好你把糖吧倒糖这边嗯
Tasha: Okay, pour the sugar over here.
Katrina: 后面的切蛋糕
Katrina: The cake at the back.
Alice:能给主厨来一块吗有点饿
Alice: Can the chef get a piece? I'm a bit hungry.
Shure: 给主厨啃一口去
Shure: Give the chef a bite.
Alice:去拿一个
Alice: Go get one.
Lucia: 哇正好
Lucia: Wow, perfect timing.
Lucia: 200克天才
Lucia: 200 grams, genius.
Lucia: 天才是怎样炼成的
Lucia: How is a genius made?
Alice:我想吃带骨头的
Alice: I want to eat the one with bones.
Jake:我还可以切一层你信不信
Jake: I can cut another layer, do you believe it?
Jake:我觉得我切嗨了
Jake: I think I cut too much.
Lucia: 真的不需要看着他点吗
Lucia: Do we really not need to watch it?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 肥一点的是吗
Shure: A bit fatter, right?
Tasha: 哎加加20克糖
Tasha: Hey, add 20 grams of sugar.
Jake:我觉得我势不可挡啊
Jake: I feel unstoppable.
Lucia: 此处应该有BGM
Lucia: This part needs background music.
Katrina: 旋转跳跃我不会
Katrina: I can't do spins and jumps.
Lucia: 我这是不是要清零一下啊
Lucia: Should I reset this?
Katrina: 这是羊肉是吧
Katrina: This is lamb, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 吧
Lucia: Right.
Shure: 来主厨请
Shure: Here you go, chef.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake:你到底切了多少层 4层
Jake: How many layers did you cut? Four?
Jake:怎么样好
Jake: How is it, good?
小薇 ：那你去把芒果切一下吧
Tasha: Then go cut the mango.
Jake:切给我好的
Jake: Cut it for me, alright.
Shure: 我刚拿那瓶啤酒
Shure: I just grabbed that bottle of beer.
Tasha: 我刚想说少一克
Tasha: I was just about to say it's one gram short.
Tasha: 我们主打一个低糖
Tasha: We're going for low sugar.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a second.
Lucia: 这这这这这啥情况
Lucia: What is this situation?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 但是另外一个他好像安的时候
Lucia: But the other one, when he installed it...
Lucia: 还没有擦干哦
Lucia: It's not dry yet.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 我还以为放那控就可以控干再擦一遍
Lucia: I thought just leaving it there to drip dry would be enough and then wipe it again.
Lucia: 哎只能呕在这
Lucia: Oh, I guess I have to do it here.
Shure: 这样是不是会更好一些
Shure: Wouldn't it be better this way?
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Lucia: 他们外面是不是可以了呀
Lucia: Are they done outside?
Tasha: 这好聪明啊
Tasha: That's so smart.
Tasha: 这是谁想出来的想法
Tasha: Who came up with this idea?
Tasha: 这样就可以了
Tasha: This should work.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Katrina: 你去拿个垃圾桶出来吧
Katrina: Can you go get a trash can?
Lucia: 下面能吃了吗
Lucia: Can we eat now?
Alice:有水吗
Alice: Is there water?
Katrina: 可以出去吧
Katrina: We can go out, right?
Lucia: 啊太好了
Lucia: Ah, great.
Alice:就就给我拿一碗水就行
Alice: Just get me a bowl of water.
Lucia: 我先把这个这个给安上
Lucia: Let me fix this first.
Jake:我也要吃嗯
Jake: I want to eat too.
Alice:自来水就行
Alice: Tap water is fine.
Katrina: 一人一个腿呀
Katrina: One leg each.
Jake:还有吗还有吗还有吗还有吗
Jake: Is there more, more, more, more?
Lucia: 好的这个你看他就是会那个啥
Lucia: Okay, see, the thing is, it will...
Lucia: 就他这边安进去之后这边就不太好安
Lucia: When you put it in here, this side doesn't fit well.
Jake:拿个小的
Jake: Get a smaller one.
Shure: 嗯嗯
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 了
Lucia: There.
Jake:哦这个可以吧
Jake: Oh, this one should work.
Shure: 这个可以吧
Shure: This one should work.
Jake:一般是多大
Jake: Usually, how big is it?
Lucia: 哦谢谢
Lucia: Oh, thanks.
Shure: 一般是多大
Shure: Usually, how big is it?
Lucia: 好的那我们先那个啥吧
Lucia: Okay, let's do that first.
Shure: 都可以都可以吃吧
Shure: Everything's edible, right?
Jake:行行行试试
Jake: Alright, alright, let's try it.
Shure: 本来反正就没有
Shure: Well, there's none anyway.
Lucia: 在这在这放一下什么水哦OK好的
Lucia: Put it here, add some water, oh okay, got it.
Shure: 主厨主厨吃到了就行
Shure: As long as the chef gets to eat.
Jake:谁管奶不都奶子吗
Jake: Who cares, isn't milk just milk?
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Damn
Shure: 来口啤酒吗
Shure: Want some beer?
Jake:吃肉了吗
Jake: Have you eaten meat?
Shure: 给你倒点尝尝
Shure: Let me pour you some to try.
Jake:吃肉啊吃了
Jake: Yes, I've eaten meat.
Katrina: 这不好喝
Katrina: This doesn't taste good.
Shure: 配着绝逼牛逼
Shure: It tastes awesome with this.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: Trust me.
Lucia: 啊终于好了是吗
Lucia: Ah, is it finally done?
Alice:我感觉我们可能吃不完
Alice: I feel like we can't finish this.
Katrina: 给
Katrina: Here.
Alice:这碳就烧没了
Alice: The charcoal is almost out.
Shure: 他说能烧5-6个小时啊
Shure: He said it could burn for 5-6 hours.
Katrina: 我倒
Katrina: I'm pouring.
Shure: 真不来点吗
Shure: Really don't want some?
Katrina: 你给我倒一点点
Katrina: Just pour me a little.
Katrina: 这啤酒很好喝哎行
Katrina: This beer tastes great, alright.
Shure: 不
Shure: No.
Shure: 撸一个串
Shure: Have a skewer.
Shure: 然后再喝一个啤酒
Shure: Then another beer.
Shure: 他很好喝
Shure: It's really good.
Katrina: 哼哼哼
Katrina: Hmm hmm.
Shure: 他绝对无敌
Shure: It's absolutely unbeatable.
Shure: 人到齐了吗
Shure: Is everyone here?
Shure: 人到齐把香槟开了
Shure: If everyone is here, let's open the champagne.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 等会我们坐里面
Lucia: Wait, let's sit inside.
Lucia: 炸羊排那羊排谁没吃着
Lucia: Who didn't get the fried lamb chops?
Jake:干羊排
Jake: Dry lamb chops.
Shure: 那羊排谁没吃着
Shure: Who didn't get the lamb chops?
Shure: 然后把那一块都吃了吧
Shure: Let's finish that piece.
Katrina: 真没吃
Katrina: Really didn't get any.
Shure: 来录录一个开香槟
Shure: Let's record opening the champagne.
Katrina: 准备就绪
Katrina: Ready.
Shure: 真就绪了吗
Shure: Really ready?
Jake:我再拿个灯下来吧
Jake: I'll get another light.
Jake:我这边也打掉
Jake: I'll turn this on too.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Okay, good.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 而且这个室室外这圈灯不亮了
Shure: Also, the lights outside aren't on.
Shure: 你没发现吗
Shure: Didn't you notice?
Alice:这个刀呢
Alice: Where's the knife?
Jake:哎为啥呀
Jake: Hey, why is that?
Alice:没有刀吗
Alice: No knife?
Jake:灯被我抢了
Jake: I took the lamp.
Shure: 谁知道呢
Shure: Who knows?
Katrina: 我来烤吧
Katrina: I'll do the grilling.
Katrina: 你开吗给你录一下
Katrina: Are you turning it on? Let me record it.
Lucia: 那我啃这个骨头了
Lucia: Then I'll gnaw on this bone.
Katrina: 跟你这样拍
Katrina: Film it like this.
Katrina: 拍高一点
Katrina: Film a bit higher.
Jake:呃我看看哈
Jake: Uh, let me see.
Jake:嗯应该可能大概
Jake: Hmm, it should probably, maybe...
Jake:谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:哎好了好了
Jake: Hey, it's done, it's done.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Shure: 准备了吗
Shure: Are you ready?
Jake:去是的是是的
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:是这么回事
Jake: That's how it is.
Tasha: 有两个插座吗
Tasha: Are there two sockets?
Jake:嗯有插
Jake: Hmm, there's a socket.
Jake:插线板对
Jake: Power strip, right.
Jake:有插有有有拖过去
Jake: There's a plug, yes, yes, yes, drag it over.
Jake:给你打个灯
Jake: I'll light it for you.
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Careful, careful.
Jake:慢点慢点慢点
Jake: Slow down, slow down, slow down.
Shure: 慢点慢点慢
Shure: Slow down, slow down, slow.
Jake:给你打灯给你打灯
Jake: I'll light it for you, I'll light it for you.
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死我了
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm dying of laughter.
Katrina: 你是某个那种晚会的
Katrina: Are you from some evening party?
Jake:瓶下留人
Jake: Leave the bottle.
Alice:有点干巴
Alice: It's a bit dry.
Alice:没声啊
Alice: There's no sound.
Jake:跟火一样打不着
Jake: It's like the fire, it won't light.
Shure: 开了吧
Shure: Turn it on.
Shure: 我就不信你今天靠气唇开不开
Shure: I don't believe you can light it with just a breath.
Shure: 他奶奶个腿的
Shure: Dammit.
Jake:看小飞行对不对吗
Jake: Look, isn't it right, little plane?
Jake:是不是39
Jake: Is it 39?
Jake:块钱的就不行了
Jake: The one for a few bucks won't work.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 没开过 39块钱的呀
Shure: I've never used the $39 one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 他妈啤酒平时喝一杯还他妈40呢
Shure: Damn, a beer usually costs 40 bucks.
Katrina: 啤酒平时喝一杯还他妈40
Katrina: A beer usually costs 40 bucks.
Shure: 好可以了
Shure: Alright, we're good.
Shure: 这回准备
Shure: This time, get ready.
Shure: 321
Shure: 3, 2, 1.
Shure: 虽然很不优雅
Shure: Although it's not very elegant.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:但是很成功
Jake: But it worked.
Katrina: 去换他一下吧
Katrina: Let's swap it out.
Katrina: 感觉他一直烤我来烤吧
Katrina: Feels like he always relies on me for the test.
Katrina: 就是翻一下就行是吧
Katrina: Just flip it, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure: 这个其实那肉就挺多的
Shure: There's actually a lot of meat here.
Jake:我继续切继续切
Jake: I'll keep cutting.
Katrina: 不如拿手吧
Katrina: Why not use your hands?
Shure: 不是这是夹炭的钱
Shure: No, that's for the charcoal.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 拿筷子翻哈哈哈
Shure: Use chopsticks to flip, haha.
Jake:好我来了
Jake: Alright, I'm coming.
Katrina: 哇这看起来好诱人啊
Katrina: Wow, this looks so tempting.
Jake:看完香槟干劲十足
Jake: After seeing the champagne, I'm pumped.
Shure: 这其实也差不多
Shure: This is pretty similar.
Lucia: 大概要打成什么样呀
Lucia: How much more do we need to beat it?
Katrina: 嗯这是牛
Katrina: Hmm, this is beef.
Katrina: 哪个部位
Katrina: Which part?
Tasha: 呃固体状就行了
Tasha: Uh, it should be solid.
Katrina: 这感觉这肉好好
Katrina: This meat feels really good.
Tasha: 这样是肯定不行的
Tasha: This won't work.
Lucia: 固体状对
Lucia: Solid, yes.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 是感觉这肉油不够吗
Shure: Do you think the meat isn't oily enough?
Shure: 嗯要不就再
Shure: Hmm, maybe we should...
Shure: 加点油
Shure: Add some oil.
Shure: 反正那是腌的
Shure: It's marinated anyway.
Katrina: 直接直接这样抹
Katrina: Just spread it directly.
Katrina: 还是再往里倒点
Katrina: Still, pour a bit more in.
Shure: 不是我直接那个
Shure: No, I'll just do it directly.
Shure: 再往里倒点
Shure: Pour a bit more in.
Katrina: 就感觉火不太旺
Katrina: It feels like the fire isn't strong enough.
Katrina: 就一般就是你那个油滴下去之后
Katrina: Usually, when you drop the oil in...
Katrina: 他不会生个小火之类的
Katrina: It doesn't just make a small flame or something.
Shure: 懂了
Shure: Got it.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: I
Katrina: 煽风点火
Katrina: Fan the flames.
Katrina: 根本不用翻
Katrina: No need to flip it.
Katrina: 都没烤熟呢
Katrina: It's not cooked yet.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 我说好像还不用翻
Katrina: I said, it seems like it doesn't need flipping yet.
Shure: 油呢
Shure: Where's the oil?
Katrina: 现在这个翻一下
Katrina: Now you can flip it.
Shure: 油呢家人们油呢
Shure: Family, where's the oil?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 那咱就盐多放水
Shure: So let's add more salt and water.
Shure: 水多放油
Shure: More water and oil.
Katrina: 搞两片来不
Katrina: Shall we do two slices?
Katrina: 放点歌听
Katrina: Let's play some music.
Tasha: 一共是7个人是吧
Tasha: There are 7 people in total, right?
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Yeah, okay.
Tasha: 那就写7个桶
Tasha: Then let's make 7 buckets.
Jake:为什么是7个人
Jake: Why are there 7 people?
Jake:那是几个人哦
Jake: How many people are there?
Katrina: 首先炒一会看看蛋还行
Katrina: First, stir-fry for a bit and see if the egg is okay.
Shure: 主要先尝一块
Shure: Mainly taste a piece first.
Alice:先尝一会
Alice: Taste it first.
Jake:6个人
Jake: 6 people.
Alice:看看淡还是咸
Alice: See if it's bland or salty.
Shure: 看看淡还是咸
Shure: See if it's bland or salty.
Jake:可以是7个人一会一会会拿一个人
Jake: It could be 7 people, but one might come later.
Jake:但是他不一定什么时候来
Jake: But they might not come anytime soon.
Jake:哎垃圾桶没了
Jake: Oh, the trash can is gone.
Shure: 直接浇上吧
Shure: Just pour it directly.
Jake:啊垃圾桶没了
Jake: Ah, the trash can is gone.
Alice:1点点
Alice: Just a little bit.
Alice:在这上面撒一点点油
Alice: Sprinkle a little oil on top.
Alice:再一点点就行
Alice: Just a little bit more is fine.
Jake:谢谢你哇
Jake: Thank you so much.
Jake:就这样的
Jake: That's it.
Tasha: 洗手我也这样洗啊
Tasha: I wash my hands like this too.
Shure: 这个应该能放下
Shure: This should fit.
Lucia: 现在呢我感觉好像
Lucia: Now, I feel like...
Jake:不应该吗
Jake: Shouldn't it?
Lucia: 对你看一眼
Lucia: Yeah, take a look.
Alice:没事没事
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Alice:好抖腕非常不错
Alice: Good shake, very nice.
Shure: 跟没抖一样是吧
Shure: It's like it didn't shake, right?
Lucia: 把这个甩一下可以了吗
Lucia: Shake this, is it okay?
Lucia: 嗯要在可以可以
Lucia: Hmm, yeah, that's good.
Lucia: 然后你看刚刚那样把这个奶油甩出来
Lucia: Then, just like that, shake the cream out.
Lucia: 然后把
Lucia: And then...
Lucia: 用刮刀把它刮到那个裱花嘴里面
Lucia: Use the spatula to scrape it into the piping bag.
Shure: 终于明白人类为什么发明蓝牙了
Shure: Now I understand why humans invented Bluetooth.
Lucia: 好的剩下这个
Lucia: Okay, this leftover...
Lucia: 这盘是干净的吧
Lucia: This plate is clean, right?
Lucia: 那我先在这放一下
Lucia: I'll put it here for now.
Katrina: 我办事我办事
Katrina: I'll handle it, I'll handle it.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Tasha: 如果你有4只手的话会不会变成猴子
Tasha: If you had four hands, would you turn into a monkey?
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Shure: 这个这不好弄
Shure: This is hard to manage.
Lucia: 那个刮刀在哪里
Lucia: Where's the spatula?
Lucia: 是不是在这边呀
Lucia: Is it over here?
Lucia: 刮刀嗯刮刀刮刀刮刀
Lucia: Spatula, hmm, spatula, spatula, spatula.
Shure: 哎呦我操
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 这烫不烫
Shure: Is this hot?
Lucia: 哈哈哈竟然在这里
Lucia: Haha, it's actually here.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:应该是烫的吧不太烫
Alice: It should be hot, but not too hot.
Shure: 不太烫不太烫吗
Shure: Not too hot, really?
Lucia: 我要把它放到
Lucia: I need to put it...
Lucia: 放到哪也要把它洗干净擦干
Lucia: Put it somewhere, and then wash and dry it.
Shure: 卧槽凉的
Shure: Whoa, it's cold.
Lucia: 嗯然后然后放到裱花袋里呃
Lucia: Hmm, then put it into the piping bag, uh...
Shure: 多绿啊不够长是吗
Shure: So green, not long enough, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Shure: 嗯操
Shure: Hmm, damn
Alice:不然你以为
Alice: What did you expect?
Shure: 太他妈艰苦了
Shure: It's so damn tough
Lucia: 可以那但是就是那
Lucia: Okay, but we need someone to hold this little flower bag
Lucia: 需要一个人撑一下这个小花袋
Lucia: Someone needs to hold this little flower bag
Shure: 先放这吧
Shure: Let's put it here first
Tasha: OK我来了
Tasha: OK, I'm coming
Tasha: 我把草莓扒完
Tasha: I'll finish the strawberries
Katrina: 眼泪收回
Katrina: Hold back your tears
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright
Jake:对啊那个裱花嘴呢
Jake: Yeah, where's the piping tip?
Katrina: 不管太多的累
Katrina: Don't worry too much about it
Shure: 尝尝这香槟吧
Shure: Try this champagne
Tasha: 裱花嘴你到底洗到哪里
Tasha: Where did you wash the piping tip?
Katrina: 感谢你的出
Katrina: Thanks for your help
Shure: 尝了吗这啤酒
Shure: Did you try this beer?
Jake:我应该放在某一个容器里爆
Jake: I should have put it in some container
Katrina: 这啤酒还不错哎
Katrina: This beer is pretty good
Katrina: 再尝一个
Katrina: Try another one
Katrina: 这个不行
Katrina: This one isn't good
Lucia: 没事至少我们还有裱花袋
Lucia: It's okay, at least we still have the piping bag
Katrina: 没有我的
Katrina: Not mine
Lucia: 有吧哦在这
Lucia: Yes, it's here
Lucia: 别我刚话音话音未落
Lucia: No, I just said it
Shure: 哎点福根都给你们
Lucia: 他发现他还找不着
Lucia: He found it, but still couldn't
Lucia: 那就比较搞笑了
Lucia: That would be funny
Katrina: 倒进去吗
Katrina: Should I pour it in?
Lucia: 对对对这里
Lucia: Yes, yes, here
Shure: 不是你先喝完这个
Shure: No, finish this first
Shure: 这不一口的事吗
Shure: It's just one sip
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Shure: 信我一口直接吞下去那种
Shure: Trust me, just gulp it down in one go
Shure: 真跟在这骗小姑娘呢哈哈哈
Shure: Really tricking the girls here, haha
Lucia: 外面有剪刀
Lucia: There are scissors outside
Jake:外边是切肉的
Jake: The ones outside are for cutting meat
Lucia: 外面那个已经剪肉了
Lucia: The ones outside are already used for cutting meat
Jake:嗯肉也
Jake: Hmm, meat too
Lucia: 嗯疯了能用
Lucia: Hmm, crazy, but usable
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 所以我们下次有哪些需要改进的
Shure: So, what improvements do we need to make next time?
Jake:那切一下
Jake: Then cut it
Lucia: 切不开我来切
Lucia: Can't cut it, let me try
Shure: 比如说碳
Shure: Like the charcoal
Katrina: 就是要早点
Katrina: We should start earlier
Jake:我来切我来切
Jake: I'll cut it, I'll cut it
Lucia: 让对让我来切
Lucia: Right, let me cut it
Shure: 碳要再多一些是吗
Shure: Should we add more charcoal?
Shure: 碳的多一点
Shure: More charcoal
Lucia: 牛啊我可以来
Lucia: Wow, I can do it
Jake:我可以来
Jake: I can do it
Shure: 就是买那种碎一点的碳是吧
Shure: Like buying the smaller pieces of charcoal, right?
Katrina: 点
Katrina: Yes
Katrina: 碳
Katrina: Charcoal
Alice:可以自己给它捣碎
Alice: You can crush it yourself
Alice:碳是可以自己给它捣碎好的但我们今天没弄
Alice: You can crush the charcoal yourself, but we didn't do it today
Jake:去哪去这去这
Jake: Where to? Here, here
Lucia: 切了
Lucia: Cut it
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Tasha: 牛啊哇啊
Tasha: Wow, amazing
Lucia: 牛啊哇
Lucia: Wow, amazing
Jake:我还没用尽呢哎
Jake: I haven't used all my strength yet
Lucia: 牛啊
Lucia: Wow
Lucia: 怎么
Lucia: What?
Jake:没我刚刚还
Jake: No, I just
Jake:我刚刚还没用尽呢
Jake: I haven't used all my strength yet
Jake:怎么就开了
Jake: How did it open?
Lucia: 了
Lucia: Already
Jake:不愧是一代高臣
Jake: Truly a great minister
Lucia: 牛啊
Lucia: Amazing
Lucia: 转世
Lucia: Reincarnated
Jake:畜牲转世
Jake: Reincarnated animal
Lucia: 重生之我是小富贵呃哈哈
Lucia: Reborn as a little rich person, haha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:能不能说点好的哈哈
Jake: Can you say something nicer, haha
Lucia: 我再想想
Lucia: I'll think about it
Lucia: 重生之我是米其林主厨
Lucia: Reborn as a Michelin chef
Jake:好这个可以
Jake: Okay, that works
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes
Shure: 这个最里面那个
Shure: The one inside the most.
Shure: 应该好吧
Shure: Should be fine, right?
Lucia: 天然香草的话就会有香草籽
Lucia: If it's natural vanilla, it'll have vanilla seeds.
Katrina: 好像没那中间有点红的
Katrina: Seems like there's no slightly red part in the middle.
Katrina: 这好了吗赘肉
Katrina: Is this done, the extra fat?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 先刮刮看
Lucia: Let's scrape it off first.
Shure: 好了这是牛肉
Shure: Alright, this is beef.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 牛排这是牛肉是吧
Katrina: This steak is beef, right?
Lucia: 这还有一点把它弄下来
Lucia: There's still a bit left, let's remove it.
Jake:第3个Mango
Jake: The third one, Mango.
Shure: 这是牛肉
Shure: This is beef.
Katrina: 反反正几分熟都能吃
Katrina: Anyway, it can be eaten at any doneness.
Lucia: 不错转化率怎么样
Lucia: Not bad, how's the conversion rate?
Katrina: 直接把哎
Katrina: Just directly, hey...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没有我开玩笑的啦
Lucia: Hahahahahaha, no, I'm just kidding.
Alice:吧
Alice: Right.
Jake:哈哈哈可以称一称
Jake: Hahaha, we can weigh it.
Katrina: 为什么这个这么软呀
Katrina: Why is this so soft?
Jake:来称称一称吧
Jake: Come, let's weigh it.
Katrina: 还是说他本来就是这么软
Katrina: Or is it supposed to be this soft?
Jake:称一称称一称称一称
Jake: Weigh it, weigh it, weigh it.
Katrina: 别的是硬的
Katrina: The others are hard.
Katrina: 他为什么是软的
Katrina: Why is this one soft?
Jake:有称吗在用是吧
Jake: Is there a scale? Are we using it?
Jake:有称没有在用
Jake: Is there a scale not in use?
Alice:放时间不太一样
Alice: The timing is different.
Alice:有个是刚上去
Alice: One just went up.
Katrina: 要不把它单独单独烤一下嘛
Katrina: How about we bake it separately?
Jake:来来来不是可以
Jake: Come on, isn't it okay?
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 转化率怎么样了
Lucia: How's the conversion rate?
Katrina: 要不要把这一块单独烤一下它好软
Katrina: Should we bake this piece separately? It's so soft.
Lucia: 哈哈我看看
Lucia: Haha, let me see.
Jake:我们看看
Jake: Let's take a look.
Tasha: 那个盒子制作的话是400克还是500克的
Tasha: Is the box made for 400 grams or 500 grams?
Alice:感觉也就这一块熟了
Alice: Seems like only this piece is cooked.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come.
Alice:其他都不太行
Alice: The others aren't quite done.
Shure: 来来
Shure: Come on, come on
Lucia: 这这上面还有草莓
Lucia: There's still strawberries on top
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Alice:跟进去吧
Alice: Let's go in
Jake:草莓没有
Jake: No strawberries
Lucia: 草莓还有糖怎么办
Lucia: What about the sugar on the strawberries?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no
Alice:放时间不太一样
Alice: The timing is different
Jake:我们一会加上去
Jake: We'll add it later
Lucia: 好开始
Lucia: Okay, start
Katrina: 甜品组跟烧烤哦
Katrina: Dessert team and BBQ
Tasha: 这是一个92克的芒果好行
Tasha: This is a 92-gram mango, okay
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 洒水是什么意思啊
Katrina: What does sprinkling water mean?
Alice:嗯让它旺一点
Alice: Uh, make it more vigorous
Jake:先就放这吧
Jake: Just leave it here first
Lucia: 就放这吧
Lucia: Just leave it here
Jake:好吧行
Jake: Alright, fine
Lucia: 好行放
Lucia: Okay, leave it
Alice:然后不那么干吧
Alice: Then it won't be so dry
Katrina: 啊洒水
Katrina: Ah, sprinkling water
Tasha: 放这再切一个就行了
Tasha: Put it here, then cut another one
Katrina: 洒水跟山峰都可以
Katrina: Sprinkling water and peaks are both fine
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 让他忘一点
Katrina: Make it more vigorous
Katrina: 然后加油也可以
Katrina: Then adding oil is also fine
Jake:一个92克的芒果
Jake: A 92-gram mango
Katrina: 是不是油是让他滴下去
Katrina: Is the oil supposed to drip down?
Alice:对油是让它滴下去
Alice: Yes, the oil is supposed to drip down
Lucia: 这剩下的芒果可以吃了对吧哈哈哈
Lucia: We can eat the leftover mangoes, right? Haha
Alice:然后就会有点小火
Alice: Then there will be a small fire
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Lucia: 蹑手蹑脚的靠近
Lucia: Sneak up quietly
Katrina: 我感觉我真的是我用反面夹去
Katrina: I feel like I really used the wrong side to pick it up
Jake:好有两个好的
Jake: Alright, two good ones
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh wow
Jake:这什么呀蚝油
Jake: What's this? Oyster sauce?
Lucia: 哇越发熟练了
Lucia: Wow, getting more skilled
Shure: 跟平时的味完全不一样
Shure: Completely different from the usual taste
Lucia: 不错熟能生巧啊
Lucia: Not bad, practice makes perfect
Tasha: 熟能生巧啊
Tasha: Practice makes perfect.
Shure: 但是我又不知道差在哪
Shure: But I don't know what's missing.
Katrina: 哈哈哈这我觉得挺好吃
Katrina: Haha, I think this tastes pretty good.
Lucia: 你看他夸一夸
Lucia: Look, he's getting praised.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我之前记得那个什么
Lucia: Haha, I remember that thing before...
Jake:哈哈哈马上菜刀就掉了
Jake: Haha, the knife will drop soon.
Katrina: 就不用自己调料
Katrina: No need to add your own seasoning.
Alice:真心
Alice: Truly.
Tasha: 只要一群女生围在他旁边夸他
Tasha: As long as a group of girls are around praising him...
Tasha: 他就会啊哈哈
Tasha: He'll start doing it, haha.
Shure: 大厨尝一块
Jake:我就会什么他就会怎么
Jake: What do you mean he'll do it?
Lucia: 哈这什么原话
Lucia: Haha, what's the original line?
Jake:菜刀就会掉了
Jake: The knife will drop.
Katrina: 拍点艺术照
Katrina: Take some artistic photos.
Lucia: 王者我也不记得反正就这个意思
Lucia: I don't remember, but that's the gist of it.
Katrina: 我又泛起了涟漪你能相信
Katrina: I'm feeling ripples again, can you believe it?
Jake:哈哈哈好厉害啊
Jake: Haha, that's impressive.
Tasha: 好厉害啊
Tasha: Impressive.
Lucia: 衣服好好看呀
Lucia: The clothes look so good.
Tasha: 衣服好好看呀
Tasha: The clothes look so good.
Tasha: 店里面衣服怎么这么好看
Tasha: How come the clothes in the store are so nice?
Shure: 淡干吧就是油少了
Shure: It's just dried lightly, with less oil.
Katrina: 就这样远远看着你
Katrina: Just watching you from afar like this.
Alice:就这样原来遇到你是我最亲爱的距离
Alice: Meeting you like this is my dearest distance.
Lucia: 能便宜点吗
Lucia: Can it be cheaper?
Jake:能便宜点吗
Jake: Can it be cheaper?
Shure: 然后还有料少了
Shure: Also, there's less seasoning.
Lucia: 再便宜点
Lucia: A bit cheaper.
Jake:能便宜点
Jake: Can it be cheaper?
Lucia: 对我好像我好像
Lucia: Yeah, I think I...
Jake:我好像朋友圈都送了
Jake: I think I sent it to my friends.
Katrina: 是我最亲密的距离
Katrina: It's my closest distance.
Lucia: 我好像刷到过这个类似的梗
Lucia: I think I've seen this joke before.
Jake:考完了
Jake: Finished the test.
Shure: 没有没有了哈哈哈
Shure: No, there's nothing left, haha.
Jake:什么什么叫没有了
Jake: What do you mean there's nothing left?
Lucia: 什么没有了
Lucia: What do you mean nothing left?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:什么叫没有了考完了
Jake: What do you mean finished the test?
Shure: 也不是
Shure: Not really.
Shure: 我拿啥呢
Shure: What am I holding?
Shure: 那个烧烤料对
Shure: That barbecue seasoning, right.
Lucia: 嗯我拿了那个辣椒粉和那个芝麻
Lucia: Yeah, I got the chili powder and the sesame seeds.
Shure: 有一个
Shure: There's one.
Lucia: 都在外面
Lucia: It's all outside.
Lucia: 你看还有啥别的
Lucia: See if there's anything else.
Shure: 有一个袋装的那个
Shure: There's one in a bag.
Katrina: 我想我和你之间的差距
Katrina: I was thinking about the difference between you and me.
Lucia: 您的盘子已经准备好了
Lucia: Your plate is ready.
Jake:好的这是什么
Jake: Okay, what's this?
Jake:这是半年总结
Jake: This is the semi-annual summary.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 刚是多少来着
Lucia: What was the number just now?
Jake:刚刚是多少单的那个数字 92
Jake: What was the number of orders just now, 92.
Lucia: 92好像
Lucia: I think it was 92.
Lucia: 不过考虑到皮和那个核
Lucia: But considering the peel and the core.
Lucia: 我们还可以有一些
Lucia: We can still have some.
Jake:不用考虑
Jake: No need to consider.
Alice:是手机响了
Alice: Is that the phone ringing?
Jake:不用考虑
Jake: No need to consider.
Lucia: 我们可以有一些depreciation了哈
Lucia: We can have some depreciation, right?
Jake:好哈哈哈自信一点
Jake: Okay, hahaha, be more confident.
Katrina: 那你去拿
Katrina: Then you go get it.
Jake:不不要考虑
Jake: No, don't consider.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Huh?
Jake:哈哈哈就要8%
Jake: Hahaha, just take 8%.
Lucia: 哈不要考虑
Lucia: Huh, don't consider.
Lucia: 你不是违背那个什么
Lucia: Aren't you violating the...
Lucia: 热力学第一定律了吗
Lucia: First law of thermodynamics?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:牛顿要出来了是吧
Jake: Newton's coming out, right?
Lucia: 热力学第一定律是谁发现的
Lucia: Who discovered the first law of thermodynamics?
Jake:那是什么东西
Jake: What's that?
Jake:牛顿
Jake: Newton.
Lucia: 管他呢反正都是牛嘴
Lucia: Who cares, it's all Newton's stuff.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 他们外面好了吗
Lucia: Are they done outside?
Lucia: 好饿哦他们
Lucia: I'm so hungry.
Jake:是啊好饿
Jake: Yeah, I'm so hungry.
Katrina: 怎么他突然就那个了
Katrina: Why did he suddenly do that?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 你平时做饭吗
Katrina: Do you cook often?
Lucia: 让我再观摩一下这个
Lucia: Let me observe this a bit more.
Katrina: 个人你比较熟练
Katrina: You seem pretty skilled.
Jake:我的4号
Jake: My number 4.
Alice:还行
Alice: Not bad.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Alice:你要你得让他把这个火生起来
Alice: You need to let him get the fire going.
Lucia: 你
Lucia: You.
Jake:4号小蛋糕
Jake: Number 4 small cake.
Alice:但是你又不能让他那个火真的烧到肉
Alice: But you can't let the fire actually touch the meat.
Alice:因为那个肉一烧他就糊了
Alice: Because if the meat burns, it'll get charred.
Lucia: 看他好可怜
Lucia: He looks so pitiful.
Alice:就焦了对
Alice: It'll get scorched, right.
Alice:所以不让他太高
Alice: So don't let the fire get too high.
Jake:他好少啊
Jake: It's so little.
Tasha: 一开始就跟他说了
Tasha: I told him from the start.
Alice:但是火大一点比较好吃
Alice: But a bigger fire makes it tastier.
Tasha: 杨老师不患寡而患不均哈哈哈
Tasha: Jake worries more about inequality than scarcity, haha.
Katrina: 这边翻一下
Katrina: Flip this over here.
Jake:看测一下
Jake: Check it.
Katrina: 这不用翻是吧
Katrina: No need to flip this, right?
Lucia: 怎么测呢
Lucia: How do we check it?
Jake:我现在在忙切
Jake: I'm busy cutting now.
Lucia: 嗯糖粉
Lucia: Hmm, powdered sugar.
Alice:你羊肉喜欢吃肥的还是瘦的
Alice: Do you prefer fatty or lean lamb?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 哎这个这个是
Lucia: Hey, this, this is...
Katrina: 我们家我吃瘦肉
Katrina: In my family, I eat lean meat.
Katrina: 我妈吃肥肉
Katrina: My mom eats fatty meat.
Jake:去哪
Jake: Where to?
Lucia: 这俩是干净的吗
Lucia: Are these two clean?
Lucia: 要冲冲吗还是
Lucia: Do they need a rinse or...
Lucia: 行反正好几天没用了
Lucia: Well, they haven't been used for days anyway.
Shure: 我油还回来了吗
Shure: Did I get my oil back?
Katrina: 这已经差不多了
Katrina: This is almost done.
Shure: 没有是吗
Shure: No, right?
Shure: 油没还回来
Shure: The oil wasn't returned.
Tasha: 就在那个烧烤架旁边
Jake:用一些用一些细枝末节的手段
Jake: Using some trivial methods.
Jake:哈哈哈在哪
Jake: Hahaha, where is it?
Jake:嗯增加1.1%
Jake: Hmm, increased by 1.1%.
Katrina: 你是哪人来着郑州
Katrina: Where are you from again? Zhengzhou?
Alice:郑州对
Alice: Zhengzhou, yeah.
Lucia: 杨老师您切的
Katrina: 我舍友也是郑州
Katrina: My roommate is also from Zhengzhou.
Lucia: 薄如蝉哈哈哈
Lucia: As thin as a cicada's wing, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈这不是适合铺在上面吗
Jake: Hahaha, isn't this perfect for spreading on top?
Katrina: 郑州到武汉只要很近
Katrina: Zhengzhou to Wuhan is really close.
Lucia: 薄如蝉哈哈哈
Lucia: As thin as a cicada's wing, hahaha.
Katrina: 一个小时
Katrina: About an hour.
Alice:因为我们那个信阳
Alice: Because our Xinyang...
Lucia: 来吧
Lucia: Come on.
Jake:好
Alice:基本上就是挨着湖北的
Alice: ...is basically next to Hubei.
Jake:我要干嘛
Jake: What should I do?
Lucia: 您就坐在这里
Lucia: Just sit here.
Jake:我坐在这里
Jake: I'll sit here.
Jake:你们也坐
Jake: You all sit too.
Shure: 这边差不多
Shure: This side is about right.
Jake:来我们一起坐
Jake: Come, let's sit together.
Alice:中间几个差不多
Alice: The ones in the middle are about right.
Tasha: 怎么一起坐
Tasha: How do we sit together?
Jake:就哈哈确实
Jake: Just... hahaha, indeed.
Lucia: 只有两个凳子呢哈哈哈
Lucia: There are only two stools, hahaha.
Jake:那我先坐
Jake: Then I'll sit first.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Lucia: 两凳子都归你了
Lucia: Both stools are yours.
Jake:哈哈哈我分分
Jake: Hahaha, I'll share.
Shure: 咱仨就守着炉子吃
Shure: The three of us will just eat by the stove.
Shure: 然后给他们分一半出去好吧
Shure: And we'll share half with them, okay?
Lucia: 坐在飞机上占用边的座位
Lucia: Taking up the window seat on the plane.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, ah.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:那我得躺着坐
Jake: Then I have to lie down to sit.
Alice:中间这几个还勉强
Alice: The ones in the middle are still barely okay.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Alice:行你要不拿一个先尝一下
Alice: Alright, why don't you take one and try it first?
Alice:这个可以
Alice: This one is good.
Alice:就变瘦的
Alice: It can make you slim.
Jake:啊我会我会我会我会
Jake: Yeah, I can do it, I can do it, I can do it.
Alice:这个不错
Alice: This is nice.
Jake:来给我我会
Jake: Give it to me, I can do it.
Tasha: 等等等等真的你不会
Tasha: Wait, wait, wait, you really can't.
Alice:别让揭下来再烤烤
Alice: Don't let it fall off, roast it more.
Alice:这个再搁那吧
Alice: Put this one there.
Tasha: 好了然后你挤一圈啊
Tasha: Okay, then you squeeze it all around.
Alice:鸡翅给他弄边嘛
Alice: Get the chicken wings to the side.
Alice:鸡翅巨难收
Alice: The wings are really hard to manage.
Alice:让他慢慢搞吧
Alice: Let him handle it slowly.
Jake:好我挤一圈
Jake: Okay, I'll squeeze it around.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:嗯你看你想吃啥你放啥
Alice: Yeah, put whatever you want to eat.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Okay, got it.
Jake:到我了
Jake: It's my turn.
Shure: 这回服务到位吗
Shure: Is the service good this time?
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Alice:好了就不管那些生了熟的了
Alice: Alright, let's not worry about what's raw or cooked.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Just leave it like this.
Shure: 我试吃一个
Shure: I'll taste one.
Katrina: 咋这么多筷子笑死
Katrina: Why are there so many chopsticks, it's hilarious.
Katrina: 这什么时候还有别的有签的呢
Katrina: When did we get more with skewers?
Lucia: 要等他把这都解完了我才能刮是吗
Lucia: Do I have to wait until he's done to scrape it?
Alice:还有别的有签的肉没了
Alice: There are no more skewered meats left.
Lucia: 哈哈哈吃熟了吗
Lucia: Hahaha, is it cooked?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:是熟了吗
Jake: Is it cooked?
Tasha: 他拿出来了说明没熟我觉得
Tasha: If he took it out, I think it's not cooked.
Lucia: 啊那咱刚吃的呢
Lucia: Ah, what about what we just ate?
Katrina: 我们自己吃就行
Katrina: We can just eat it ourselves.
Lucia: 不知道那个感觉还行吧
Lucia: I don't know, it seems alright, right?
Jake:那个感觉还行吧
Jake: It seems alright, right?
Shure: 不是特别熟
Shure: It's not very cooked.
Jake:这玩意是羊肉牛肉
Jake: Is this lamb or beef?
小薇 ：突然觉得我手洗过了
Tasha: Suddenly I feel like I've washed my hands.
Lucia: 没事反正咱一直在这做饭呢对就是
Lucia: It's okay, we've been cooking here all along, right?
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:卫生等级a
Jake: Hygiene rating A
Jake:这边是怎么分呢
Jake: How do they classify it here?
Jake:卫生等级哦OK
Jake: Hygiene rating, oh okay
Lucia: 好像是有a b c啊
Lucia: I think it's A, B, C
Alice:哎会掉
Alice: Oh, it'll fall
Alice:嗯没事
Alice: Hmm, it's fine
Lucia: 但是一般来说好像也无人在意
Lucia: But generally, no one really cares
Alice:一会用得搁到这上面
Alice: We'll need to put it on top later
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:现在好了
Jake: It's fine now
Shure: 杨老板你就吃吧
Shure: Jake, just eat it
Shure: 肯定死不了
Shure: You won't die
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 你就闭着眼睛吃吧
Shure: Just close your eyes and eat it
Alice:泪湿了眼神
Alice: Tears welled up in my eyes
Shure: 闭眼闭眼 的是吧
Shure: Close your eyes, right?
Tasha: 他就像那个来上学的diy
Tasha: It's like he's doing a DIY school project
Tasha: 蛋糕手工课
Tasha: Cake making class
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 哈哈是吧
Shure: Haha, right?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 没问题吧
Shure: No problem, right?
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 还活着哈哈
Shure: Still alive, haha
Shure: 没问题这还有一个
Shure: No problem, there's still one more
Jake:还活着
Jake: Still alive
Shure: 这绝对熟了哈哈
Shure: It's definitely cooked, haha
Jake:哈哈哈啥
Jake: Hahaha, what?
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊谢谢
Lucia: Hahaha, ah thank you
Shure: 哈没有一个人敢自己放手里吃是吧
Shure: Haha, no one dares to eat it by themselves, right?
Katrina: 嗯你先把那边清空
Katrina: Hmm, you clear that side first
Jake:意思这绝对熟啊
Jake: Meaning it's definitely cooked
Alice:来赏你一块
Alice: Here, have a piece
Shure: 来喽来喽
Shure: Here it comes, here it comes
Alice:你尝尝
Alice: Try it
Tasha: 我们到时候把最上面一层抹一下就行好看
Tasha: We'll just spread the top layer later to make it look good
Alice:他刚说不太熟
Alice: He just said it's not fully cooked
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: It's fine
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 加高一下他
Tasha: Raise it up a bit for him
Shure: 应该差不多
Shure: It should be about right
Lucia: 然后我们
Lucia: And then we...
Alice:熟不熟
Alice: Is it cooked?
Shure: 吃的好像还有点嫩
Shure: Seems like it's still a bit undercooked
Jake:跟杜雅拿个凳子来
Jake: Get a stool from Doya
Lucia: 嗯没事没事我这样就行了
Lucia: Hmm, it's fine, it's fine, I can manage like this
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This...
Shure: 熟了熟
Shure: It's cooked, cooked
Jake:有有有我屋里多的很
Jake: Yeah, yeah, I have plenty in my room
Lucia: 对乖
Lucia: Yes, good boy
Shure: 了
Shure: Done
Lucia: 哦那也行
Lucia: Oh, that works too
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Jake:我的
Jake: Mine
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 原来是某些人私藏了
Lucia: So some people were hiding it
Alice:这是比较早搁进去
Alice: This was put in quite early
Jake:对我的黑工办公室
Jake: Yes, in my secret office
Lucia: 那我就先鸠占鹊巢了
Lucia: Then I'll just make myself at home
Shure: 这不能直接放
Shure: This can't be placed directly
Shure: 它会漏下去
Shure: It will leak
Shure: darling just kiss me slow on my own
Shure: Darling just kiss me slow on my own
Jake:我要干嘛
Jake: What am I supposed to do?
Tasha: 您再起还剩这么多奶油吗
Tasha: Do you still have this much cream left?
Jake:好来了
Jake: Alright, coming
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎你俩这个时候你来
Lucia: Hahaha, hey, you two came at this time
Tasha: 哎你这怎么放啊
Tasha: Hey, how are you placing this?
Katrina: 他们在做蛋糕
Katrina: They're making a cake
Katrina: 做了两三种好像
Katrina: Seems like they made two or three kinds
Jake:有救
Jake: There's hope
Lucia: 就能把它再弄上去吗
Lucia: Can you put it back on?
Katrina: 主要是杨靖康有点搞笑
Katrina: Mainly, Yang Jingkang is a bit funny
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: you between my arm
Shure: You between my arms
Lucia: 是这是是这样吗
Lucia: Is this how it goes?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 对哎
Lucia: Yes, right
Lucia: 那就是其实只用一个包也行对吧
Lucia: So actually, using just one bag is fine, right?
Shure: barefoot on the grass
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 对好吧这蛋糕太小了
Lucia: Alright, this cake is too small.
Lucia: 没没必要那么大的
Lucia: There's no need for such a big one.
Shure: 我就不不不喂你俩了
Shure: I just won't feed you two anymore.
Jake:我觉得我怎么挤都没关系对吧
Jake: I think it doesn't matter how I squeeze it, right?
Tasha: 对但是你这不是增加人家工作量
Tasha: Yeah, but aren't you increasing their workload?
Tasha: 你再把边边一圈加高一下
Tasha: You can raise the edges a bit more.
Shure: 每次都抱一双新筷子
Shure: Every time I grab a new pair of chopsticks
Shure: 然后发现哎
Shure: Then I realize, oh
Shure: 我刚才有筷子
Shure: I already had a pair.
Jake:没事给下一层吧
Jake: It's okay, give it to the next layer.
Shure: 来大叔随便吃点吧
Shure: Come on, uncle, just eat something.
Alice:大叔谢谢
Alice: Thank you, uncle.
Jake:没了是吧
Jake: Is it all gone?
Lucia: 也行反正反正会用到
Lucia: It's fine, we'll use it anyway.
Tasha: 嗯好我还挤一圈
Tasha: Okay, I'll squeeze another layer.
Shure: 自己家孩子怎么看都好看
Shure: Your own kids always look good to you.
Jake:对好再补一补
Jake: Yeah, let's add a bit more.
Jake:哎呀没事
Jake: Oh, it's okay.
Jake:好玩好玩好玩好玩好玩
Jake: Fun, fun, fun, fun, fun!
Jake:好玩好玩好玩
Jake: Fun, fun, fun!
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh my
Jake:真的这么多
Jake: Really, this much?
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my
Lucia: 我们
Lucia: We
Lucia: 这个最后会不会高超过他的长宽啊
Lucia: Will this end up taller than its length and width?
Alice:这个差不多给
Alice: This is almost done.
Shure: 谢谢大厨
Shure: Thank you, chef.
Tasha: 啊什么东西
Tasha: Ah, what is it?
Lucia: 就是这个
Lucia: It's this
Lucia: 这个圆柱
Lucia: This cylinder
Lucia: 体的h超过他的直径哈哈哈
Lucia: Its height is longer than its diameter, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈OK就是他是一个长的
Jake: Haha, okay, so it's long
Jake:不是一个扁的
Jake: Not flat.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:一个高个小蛋糕对
Jake: A tall little cake, yeah.
Lucia:  对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 怎么样跳一段会吗
Shure: How about dancing a bit?
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmph.
Katrina: 不会这个歌吗你会跳
Katrina: Can't you dance to this song?
Lucia: 那样就会有点不太好切
Lucia: That would be a bit difficult to cut.
Lucia: 就是切了之后就容易倒
Lucia: It tends to fall over after cutting.
Shure: 不是我说这个
Shure: No, that's not what I meant.
Lucia: 没事管他呢
Lucia: It's okay, don't worry about it.
Katrina: 嗯不会
Katrina: Hmm, no, I can't.
Katrina: 你会
Katrina: Can you?
Shure: 要学吗
Shure: Want to learn?
Jake:这汉堡挺好哈哈哈
Jake: This burger is pretty good, haha.
Katrina: 又会跳舞又会唱歌又会弹吉他牛啊
Katrina: You can dance, sing, and play the guitar, amazing!
Lucia: 哈哈哈救命
Lucia: Haha, save me!
Lucia: 这边稍微有点这边稍微有点矮
Lucia: This side is a bit lower.
Lucia: 就是这边高一点这边矮一点
Lucia: This side is higher, and this side is lower.
Tasha: 我给他刮一下把这拖上去
Tasha: I'll scrape it up a bit to lift it.
Katrina: 嗯好
Katrina: Okay.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 这种三排的就适合
Shure: This three-row setup is just right.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 我也忘了那叫什么舞了反正
Shure: I forgot what that dance is called anyway.
Katrina: 好吃
Katrina: Tasty.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Alice:应该差不多了
Alice: It should be almost done.
Jake:不是主要这个表面很像汉堡
Jake: The surface really looks like a burger.
Jake:要点肉我要
Jake: I want some meat.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈甜
Lucia: Haha, sweet.
Lucia: 都是咸的你不觉得很奇怪吗
Lucia: It's all savory, don't you think that's weird?
Jake:我要干嘛我要干嘛
Jake: What am I doing, what am I doing?
Lucia: 再挤
Lucia: Squeeze again.
Jake:再挤一圈再挤一圈
Jake: Squeeze another round.
Shure: 应该都熟了
Shure: It should be done.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 你们吃吧
Shure: You guys eat.
Alice:抖了一
Alice: Shaking a bit
Jake:对这个应该就是区别于汉堡的
Jake: Yeah, this should be different from a burger
Alice:下
Alice: Down
Lucia: 圈
Lucia: Circle
Jake:最重要的一层对
Jake: The most important layer, right
Shure: 跟我妈整的差佬
Shure: Just like what my mom made
Shure: 这玩意怎么看着都是一样的步骤
Shure: This thing seems to follow the same steps
Katrina: 母爱吧哈哈哈
Katrina: It's motherly love, haha
Shure: 哈哈哈别玩大的好吗哥们
Shure: Haha, don't mess with the big ones, okay buddy
Alice:差不多了
Alice: Almost done
Lucia: 这这外围
Lucia: This, the outer part
Jake:我等会我捋一捋我
Jake: Wait, let me sort this out
Lucia: 这个你小心别把他吊在这个上面
Lucia: Be careful not to hang it on this
Jake:捋一捋
Jake: Sort it out